this point you're in a Las Vegas hotel
room with your newly married lesbian
wife Marie by Elvis yeah okay a cocaine
hooker make sure you watch the lot your
[__]
people keep saying it was Lawrence you
know you kind of you kind of top this
guest you kind of top this guest no you
know we and we never will
let's just stop there and raise the [__]
involvement right this dude has had an
un-fuckin'-believable life now we've had
guests on before who've had amazing
Rises we've had some who had amazingly
bad hard times you've had both yeah and
that is what makes you a very
interesting bloke man thank you
I think we should start with a success
you know what how did you find success
in life early on I just growing up in
the northwest
a little town called Witness and
chemical manufacturing but not much
money but I've got interested in stock
market age 14 unusually teachers giving
me classes on my own explain how to be
differential times what made you think
about that I watched that movie where
greed is good Gordon Gekko Wall Street
yeah so far yeah you know this is a way
I can make millions and live this you
know big life and I was just dazzled by
the American scene because I visited as
a teenager get off the plane in Arizona
you know the heat hits you you see all
the swimming pools in the backyards as
you're coming in to land I'm like no
this is paradise coming from witness
history you were supposed to be like an
entrepreneur at heart Lord because not
many 14-year olds are thinking about the
stock market out there I was an
entrepreneur cuz at school before that
in at the dinner hour I'd run to the
shop buy loads of sweets go back selling
for twice the price of the kids get bin
about shoes
those things a lot of people say they
would sort of be doing those
entrepreneurial things as a kid and sort
of find a ways to cheat the system in a
way but also you're almost like Robin
Hood yeah you know I've got a meal on me
fair summer no question not the best
question so wait you went to Arizona at
14 no no at 14 I started to do economics
in my high school yeah the teacher
explained to me how the stock market
works how to read the financial times
six differential times financial times
right was so what what what why are you
why are they explaining to you how to
read fine
right I was so interested in the stock
market this young age he was giving me
classes on my own okay oh so he must
have thought you were gifted to do yeah
yes something like that and in at
sixteen aboard fifty quid off mine and
doubled it in be teachers and I was it
now a Salama made some little town I'm
going to America I'm gonna make a
million I'm gonna fly all you guys over
and I still am questioning whether
that's a good idea
at the age what were your parents saying
what and why is your nan giving you 50
credit you like she believed in you or I
went to me dad and he was a labor
supporter and it was Maggie Thatcher's
privatizations and he told me to bugger
off Joshi subject yeah so I knew my
Nan's voted for Maggie Bloomberg in the
witness area family members or the
prophets they all started to jump or
even they knew dad still go in I mean we
had a poker player in a while but it
just seemed like you are when you're
playing the stocks it is a gamble yes
there's a bit like that isn't it
in you're betting that money that the
stocks can arise but you is it true that
nobody really knows what's gonna happen
I do you have tips and tricks that you
can pick up before you put your money
down okay we were in a unique time in
England in the stock market back then
all the major companies that the
government home we're getting sold off
yeah mostly to banks so they were
selling him dirt cheap at the taxpayers
expense
that's what that's why nowadays there
are a lot of people calling the bank's
banksters yeah because of the way
they've ruined the economy is right
totally and this was when it was
happening this is when they were
originally selling big companies off
British Gas you know the telecom
national rail yeah exactly so I jumped
on that to be fair everyone else in that
area is probably going [__] this I can't
believe what's going on here and you're
thinking 50 pence you buy it 50 pence
the next thing opens a quid hmm you've
doubled you money yeah yeah and so at
that time what why do you seem that how
had you seen how would that come around
because it's not usual for a child to go
down the route of thinking stocks and
shares that's amazing
it can't just be you saw a movie and
when I'm gonna do that that's hard to
get into as a 14 year old I had this
entrepreneurial spirit and when I did
economics someone just clicked in my
head about the stock market just got
this unnatural distraction to it and you
understood this it how it worked well I
didn't know but I've got some obsessed I
had the teacher giving these lessons and
I went down the library and they ordered
loads of books on the subject of styrene
everything so I've got this manic energy
that I just throw into something I
forget do you feel looking back now
because there's times where I look back
on my life and it was almost like
YouTube was like almost telling as I
because every time I ended up doing a
job
it was YouTube was always there in the
background for some reason and I'm like
was that was I meant to end up here
doing this and do you feel like it was
like you were just meant to do that at
that time in your life I did at that
time yes yes this day yeah it's in my
DNA you just can't help yourself no help
myself
well count him Deepti you still double
my time now he's fully occupied as an
offer on a public speaker so I don't
really have the time and you're not ever
tempted to get back into that I will
down the road
yeah yeah yeah if you have only ten
business partners where we trust you
understand so when did you go to the
states the first time all right visit as
a teenager and you know the planes
coming in and you see you're looking
down you've seen all this when we pulled
into backyards and as soon as the girls
hear your accent oh my god you know the
Beatles you know the Queen always kind
of thing there are the red carpet
thinking you know just for being a plain
person in the UK I've got it maybe yeah
you do to them I guess you look and
sound like Paul McCartney or like it's
funny you should say that because to get
in a club in America you gotta be I
think it's like 21 my aunt
changed my fate as boyfriend my passport
taught me club in when she was
introducing me to all these American
women as Paul McCartney's nephew
brilliant does seem a lot like your
whole family's a bit so where are you
going as a young kid Arkansas you say no
Arizona Arizona that's a so you went to
come visit you're on in Arizona yeah and
that's why you were in Arizona which
isn't the most usual place to sort of
visit for a holiday is it not for an
English person so English was curse so
we had this scarcity value yeah so
wherever you went people are really
friendly to you yeah you ignoble enough
exactly okay yeah and that must be quite
an experience as young I was a shy
teenager after the usual anxiety and
stuff like that and to go down and all
of a sudden you know I got all this
attention it just goes right to your
head and then did you go to university
to study oh wow I went to uni other
appeal did Business Studies that was
around the time the rave scene started
in this country so that became me over
passion well that was your other passion
yeah partyin partyin now you're talking
my language
in live again yeah it was it was
Manchester went off a thing and
Liverpool and the same time London
what was the was this around that
Trainspotting era were you were you bit
older than that are talking like 1989
1990 because the 91 I went to Arizona
and Perman right okay so
so you were on a you that was when club
music was at its up sort of picking
people break into work house playing
hangars police chasing everybody in and
you're part of that that was what was
that like to be part well before that to
get in a club gets a dress in a suit and
tie and the bouncers come out left you
in the queue for aid he's looking down
at you people were sick of it
and this new style of Musa just came
along and the kids could just were
whatever they want all these psychedelic
clothes baggy jeans sneakers and getting
chased by the police on these convoys on
the motorway and it was just the buzz
mm-hmm it's like a revolution in music
at that time yeah and it was sort of a
reaction what was going on politically
as well of that time you probably never
almost so gray and bland and boring we
haven't really had anything in this
country since then that was like that
I think people sort of jumped on hip hop
in a similar way doesn't grind music
maybe you could argue something like
that movie I culturally it hasn't
proliferated the mainstream as much as
that maybe did this revolution in music
before I was probably pull rocked and
then you had all the soccer hooligan but
in all the ecstasy heads that going the
super clubs from all these little towns
and hugging each other and yeah yeah
don't worry love you slack so you
obviously discovered the music
discovered than you see and you discover
drugs yeah and with that yeah yeah what
was your first experience with drugs
alright I had anxiety and it was
compounded because they almost got beat
to death as a teenager when I went to
fill up my mom's all red car petrol just
passed my driver's license assessed and
some drunks like picking on me he
thought it was brave to stand up to him
and just kick him in the head hit me in
the face of an iron bar knocking pieces
of myth he felt basically left me for
dead
so that compounded my anxiety and then
when I went to a rave for the first time
sort of ecstasy all that stress
intention that I had just melted away
because before that I wasn't caught and
danced off too self-conscious what got
them sorts of women one sort of
strangers Amani I'm smiling all night
long hugging people meeting women and
just making friends with strangers and
you know it just
I just got totally immersed in it yeah I
think a lot of people when they first
that experience in the I've got all that
pent-up [__] and it just cause they are
likely to try it again after that on
there yeah I got addicted to the
lifestyle yeah and that feeling and the
drug they say that drugs not what I did
get addicted to well it by the end of it
when I was running this ecstasy business
I got addicted to the attention always
getting the ego but money I was making
the fast cash just a lifestyle playing
cops and robbers you know avoiding the
cops that buzz off that the adrenaline
high so there's a number of factors if
you've got a propensity towards
addiction like me stimulate that yeah
and that must be so early on obviously
you don't know that you're just a kid
you're just taking drugs joy experience
and all of this and it's all melting the
way all that all up end of [__] and your
dance and the [__] head off and yeah
enjoy your life's at this point in years
I didn't think I was an interesting
enough person to be around unless I was
high but you're always chasing those
early huh you solved that problem
you were not insecure but sort of quite
an anxious person I was I was insecure
as well if it wasn't on drugs yeah you
self-conscious
you know I feel like I've met a lot of
people who are a bit like that the way
but until they have an alcoholic drink
even sometimes that and there's a few
lads I know you like you need good for
trouble vodka redbulls and before you
got a chat with them do you know like
this yeah does that type of person they
don't feel very confident for it takes
them a lot to but then once they that
you cannot stop them yeah they're on the
dance floor and come down me stop
hugging all those but see police car
you're on top
it's a bit like that with some loud so I
feel like I know that looks exactly
there's a lot of people out there like
that so by day you were studying money
Business Economics those sort of things
was that and through those that decade
was that he was still interested in that
and in the beginning in Arizona
I got work as a stockbroker okay if
you've watched a wolf of Wall Street you
know that's just glorified telesales why
did you choose to go to Arizona
sorry cuz man okay as a teenager saw the
you know the Sun the swimming pools the
size of the houses the roads the cars so
that was gonna be my Mecca and but not
because traditionally financially it's
New York isn't yes why not New York and
I wanted to be an investment analyst and
New York was the hope for that so for
all right just to get me started
oh I'll go as a stockbroker because
there's a big stockbroker community in
Arizona because there's a lot murder
okay that's a call five hundred numbers
a day Commission only at first wasn't
making any money it got down to the
point where I was living off cheese and
sauce and bananas and I thought was
enough to come home was living off my
shoe and credit cards but five years in
then you know I was I was a top going
office got in half a million Wow got my
own staff secretary call calls and any
other enough money to retire from that
basically but I continued to trade stock
market online join the dot-com bubble
well now what time we're talking here
we're talking late nineties now and that
was our made a couple of million okay
yeah and you just traded your way up
trading my way up and what kind of
things are you investing in at that time
the biggest success I had was in an
Indonesian satellite company okay slot
called Pacific satellite nan cetera and
I bought 30-something thousand shares
about five dollars not one alarm went up
so over fifty dollars during the.com
bubble and the other one over sure a lot
of technology shows and so that was you
say that was your speciality was
technology the technological side of
things investing in technology companies
technology and biotech I've got the most
volatility so if you're a risk-taker you
can make the big bucks if you know what
you're doing
my specialty is a form of investing
called technical analysis we look at
charts and volume patterns and you kind
of try and recognize surges in trading
volume that indicate in decide
Saida buying because the inside is know
what's gonna come so if you can
piggyback that and a stock's trending up
above it 150 day moving average you got
all these other green lights you jump on
you've got your probabilities narrowed
right down with stress
so you're basically banking on people
with people doing something illegal and
benefiting off the back of insider
trading is illegal but no one hardly
ever gets you can't record for it
basically yes every now and then you
make an example of someone boy it's so
corrupt out there so how does it feel
when you put all the eggs in one basket
and you say you're taking off and you're
thinking [__] it's almost like you're
watching a horse race you know when you
see in people going crazy
are you watching those numbers going up
and just celebrating like [__] I mean
I moved into a gated guarded community
into a million dollar house on the side
of a mountain I married the woman who
was doing lesbian internet porn
we were just getting limo rides all over
the place pissing the money away
throwing after parties for days on end
for my mates just giving them all free
drugs just just went completely out of
control you tube details in that story
now that's one thing he dropped in there
that wasn't your first wife that was it
our free wives
yeah was it all at the same time Wendy
go mama
Wednesday get your first wife when I
moved to America I met a woman in a bar
a Korean woman and I was actually being
sensible now I was off I was off the
drugs for a period and I was looking to
just build my career and she asked me if
I would come over to her apartment the
next week and help him move a piano sure
wasn't it wasn't Yoko Ono just died
[__] share this grand Chun piano that
wouldn't budge
what [__] I used to be now is a true
story about piano could you play her
keys she should cut the nice chicken
curry that's a good way to my heart
started to go back every week and that's
how we got together you play the piano
yeah I thought then that's it the drugs
thing was over
I'm married I'm gonna have a normal life
until six months later a mental illness
came out she met alone yeah she said she
said a lot I'm older than you I feel
more comfortable who got married I said
you heard that sounds cool let's do it
another green card at the time she was
American she was she had a green Cassius
Clay originally so come off and work one
night after we married shower-curtain
boss open like in psycho trying to slice
my man parts off with a Ginsu knife Wow
yeah we gotta wrong I'm figuring out
every man in the room they just got
married to someone they got an issue you
love them you gotta work through it when
the doctor put her on Zoloft if it was
fine fight was over a year later sister
comes over from Korea I'm working
stockbroker in the high-rise near the
top living in this little building near
the bottom three days later I'm come
home from work
this has been cooking and stuff it's
been happy wife's got this look on her
face like she wants to kill me again
like what's the matter
my sister food or medicine away she said
it was Western poison and you're in a
conspiracy with my doctor to try and
kill me with it right so I'm like no no
it's not the case she runs around that
smashing everything up frauds plates at
me plate smashes the jackets at the
coffee table glass into these jagged
pieces I've gotta be up for work the
next day five o'clock in the morning I
gotta be up six bucks sales meeting lock
myself in the bedroom leave them to it
get up at 5:00 wake up they are asleep
I'm a shower I'm a piss brush my teeth
get my suit on I'm going through the
living room about to open the door
wife's eyes just do the Dracula thing
bust open she launches at me like a cat
mouth
former man parts mrs. maddack by it's a
hole in my suit so there's Clough dangle
enough atif starts to smash things up
again and I figure [__] works all myself
in the bedroom again
call the cops say look can you take my
wife to make one of her mates houses
she's gone ballistic I've gotta get to
work
if I put the cops of some use so they
come out to redneck cops come out the
bedroom they're looking at my wife she's
lying on the floor drooling crying a
sister's no over doing the sign of the
Cross train these redneck cops like
what's going on in here
guy I explained she's from the medicine
away there all right we'll take it to
the friends house they leave thinking
all right it's all over I sit on the
sofa I always knew your corner was
something wrong with her OSS Vic pick up
the phone call the office the bats
talents I'm gonna be late for work
front door bursts open
she's give the cops lip she comes
running in grabs the iron from the
countertop she's about to plant into my
skull I've got just enough time to go
like this and block her she bounces off
me
lands on the coffee table that she
smashed into jagged pieces the night
before all the glass Nick Zinner
and blood squirting out of her and the
cops come running in like what have you
done to her
so next thing I'm outside with 10 cops
in the circle beard about to arrest me
police woman comes forward should know
II call this in so this won't happen
look at him he's the victim of domestic
violence that scratches I love my face
my neck all my shirt was ripped
she's just run off after you the clue
could have been when they lost ya or
Dava you know how she's of it did she
look Asian this woman because I'm
imagining you have you ever seen like is
it the ring or those Japanese sort of
horror films oh they're like
next one I didn't marry you in the
technical sense in the core she
collected serial killer how did you meet
this one all right so after the after
the last one went to a nightclub are you
are you back partying no so I'm so yeah
this has got my stress I would turn me
this back up now stress level back up
not making excuses decided to go back to
drugs club meet a woman she's a former
Calvin Klein model been in a car crash
got addicted to painkillers and is now
addicted to crystal meth and he's
packing a handgun and I thought that was
exciting meth meth does [__] the
appearance though doesn't it eventually
eventually yeah yeah you know the
chemicals that take the enamel off your
teeth it comes out your skin so I've
seen these before mess and after mess
pictures yeah and it's unbelievable how
bad it makes me a loss yeah well she was
still she was stunning and so you know I
was I was all over her and one of the
things that tried to be so it was when
we first met I went over to her house
she couldn't move the waterbed she just
pulls this gun out and just shoot him I
need you to come over to my house to
move some [__] ironically so as you can
imagine
oh alright we didn't get made in the
court she collected serial-killer books
she loved Natural Born Killers yeah so
we went to this area beautiful it's just
saying yeah go with it so she gets a
razor blade out and just slashes our
hands and then commingled our blood that
was how she wanted to do it Wow okay so
you were you were married by blood by
blood bond okay and how did that one
well that one escalated you know with
the drugs that my child doing and it
didn't work out very well and then the
third one came along
she won't know did didn't work out very
well it's like the bad dog he was just
yeah argument yeah argument I'm staying
out all night roommates on drugs she's
not thinking that she eventually settled
down and got a real estate license and I
continue to escalate alrighty
yeah so how did you meet the third one
would have put the brakes on but I
didn't listen
uh-huh yeah third one I was this is the
lesbian yeah yeah I was I was getting
together with a woman at a rave yeah it
was a fix for the half asian half
American
her name was pepper and she was used to
me I think you fall in love over she's
won were maids I'm gonna bring it down
from Tucson and she did she just brought
it down and said she's on chemistry at
University and figured I could come in
handy from manufacturing MDMA so you
were sort of into manufacturing drugs
buy my MDMA was getting manufactured in
Holland I did have a guy who was
manufacturing LSD let's wait because not
many people say my MDMA was getting
manufactured in Holland yeah so you're
you're making a [__] ton of cash at this
point when you meet her when you finally
meet the third girl yeah this is when
the money's rolling in and you are
ballin out of control you've got
everything going and you're sitting
there thinking yourself I know I'll make
me on - me on gear
is that is that what company ahead or
did you meet people who told you you
know why don't you do this to that was
there anyone who you met it's a function
of profit margin so as you go higher up
the drug scale you want to operate in a
way that's going to maximize your
profits cuz there this business that
he's a Greece I'm applying on my
business the descri knowledge for
example how to my I had about 200 people
working for me each was in a faction
each faction had a head and we'd have
like crime family dinner each month
where the heads of each factions would
go but back to your question let me just
go back our started out so in the
beginning I'm just Hawking my mates up
with ecstasy and I'm showing off
basically I've got the most money and
buying friends
and you'd attract a lot of people when
you're giving it away for free gyul so
then let's start to see the business
potential of it you know 2530 dollars a
hit it's going for on the streets and
the clubs in Arizona what that's for one
extra warm pill so I'm thinking alright
I'll buy fifty or a hundred from the
local dealers and see how it goes as an
experiment and you know we made we made
some Bank
but that's all they could supply us with
fifty two hundred local dealers but you
you already had millions off of the
Stockman ah so it wasn't to be doing it
it wasn't a necessity I was just great
at this greed yeah yeah yeah totally and
emotionally maturity I'm thinking I'm
somebody I'm a character now in this
scene so local dealers could only give
us 50 to 100 pills so I'm going to find
out where they're getting it start
getting out of LA then LA I can get 500
to 5,000 so for a year to start I'm
going through LA and then it's just
getting bigger and bigger so we need to
get more we need to get the price down
so I'll send people out to Holland and
they hooked up with the guys in Holland
and the price comes down in Holland
slowly you know like four dollars a pill
include enough hold cost of the mission
sending people out there down to like
three dollars down to like two dollars
and it gets to the point where they
basically say we can manufacture your
own pill and put your own press on it
and do your own design and stuff like
that which the Eagle Eagle maniac in you
would have loved I would assume at that
point because it's yours
you're making your own thing yeah what's
up right oh I didn't actually pursue
that option I've been a for if I bid a
press that was my pill that's basically
a red flag for a cops so you're gonna be
all over that actually for about putting
the rival Sammy the bull Gravano
everybody yeah so you've got to the
point just before that and you stop
there and sort of just got a trip I'm
not gonna put a price on any more you
were just getting I was going to cheap
rent she put in cheaper yeah how many
can you remember the most amount you
ever bought in one go
yeah totally 3040 thousand pills and
here's the thing you can't do this if
anyone's watching thinks they couldn't
do this this was pre 9/11 so I would
send people we don't recommend it
regardless of 9/11 but
after that yeah don't do it yeah we're
not right we're not saying this isn't a
handbook in how to do this but 40 gone
going but boy I had lawyers giving me
advice for smuggling methods as you're
taking drugs with them essentially
you're giving that lawyers drugs I'm
sending them to business people are
getting arrested are the legal benefits
of my organization was if you get busted
you get a lawyer you get bailed out yeah
and you keep your mouth shut
yeah don't sweat it cuz we're going to
give you everything possible to help you
yeah you've not got criminal record
you're not going to do any time you
don't need to snitch so you're all right
violence wise you're not a gangster but
you're are operating in almost
everywhere as a gangster at this point
when you go up that hierarchy
you're gonna bump heads with gangsters
like Sammy the bull Gravano on the boss
of the Gambino crime family
Ede murdered almost two dozen people and
his son told me he'd been dispatched one
night it's kidnapped me from a nightclub
and take me out to the desert he told me
that later on in prison I didn't know
cuz I'm storing the drugs at the time so
when I was so but I heard that like what
have you just done for the last ten
years how could you put yourself in all
these dangerous situations because you
were their competitor at this point I
was anything goes but because I had the
protection of the New Mexican Mafia I'm
thinking I can get away with things how
did you get that protection alright as
I'm rising up in the ecstasy business I
never touch any other drug so it
interrupt again well as he had 200
people working for me
those people were we did we did build up
and deal some other drugs within the
club scene actually was the main thing
that was my trademark properly arising
over that business so I'm at an
apartment party and it's like in a town
called Tempe Park near Phoenix which is
like a university town so the students
and clubbers in the smoking weed doing
coke and I've come to supply some
ecstasy and there's a Mexican American
guy rugged-looking dude got the prison
tats and he's come to supply some
marijuana and some coke so we just were
just bonding and talking I'm just
getting to meet this guy and he seems
pretty cool he's laid-back
he didn't come across as menacing and
then a policeman just walks in he's like
I could smell the weed nobody move and
he's reaching for his radio and he's
about to call in a novice all arrested
so the Mexican guy I'm talking to she
also is gone points out the carp the
only one who's not leaving is you
[__]
everyone go so we all just went out into
the name so I'm crapping myself I've not
been in any front light as heavy as this
right
a ghost roommates apartment who's
dealing E for me in the same complex and
we're sat in police cars everywhere
sirens helicopters out next thing bang
bang bang bang bang it's the dude the
Mexican American dude he's on that he's
at the French window let me in let me in
so bright we open the door let him in
and then he schools us he's like if the
police come you can't just walk in you
just don't answer the door they got have
a warrant they've just been sent out
they don't have a warrant they can't
come in so if the earthly knock just
don't answer so we just stayed in there
in the dark please everywhere waits on
the left and I said to him at the end of
it I said lot you you're hot in this
area why don't I just ate some house
tonight so while things cool down I
still didn't know who it was and I did
and we started hanging out and he said
look Shawn cause you and your friends
protected me that night my brothers are
gonna have your back didn't know what
that meant
right mom's late he says my brother's
finally want to meet you so I'll go over
to this street in Tempe there's all his
lowrider show cars on the street
his brother answers head shaved short
guy stocky he's just looking at me like
they would go I mean look these guys
like the prison looks and I go in and go
through massive mexican-american guy's
tats wifebeaters shorts down below the
knees chains and it's just like you know
it was the skinny English guy and
they're like the main get the guy who
answered his bravas that's was enough
max and and I look over in the living
room they've got the biggest TV I've
ever seen got this CCTV screen as well
looking at all the cars on the street
and then on top of the TV is a
rocket-propelled grenade launcher
launcher telly I usually would decorate
a TV but one way into each other so I
[__] myself and what they wanted to try
so they're all looking at me
one of them to be fair I if I would as
you I would have been hard no like
[__] Tic Tacs me
sounds like I made them a lot nicer yeah
first night first night I went into one
of the biggest ones he just shoved a
bunch of coke in my face and said snort
this cuz you know if you're not going to
start your cup or whatever and I started
here and I come to find out later on he
was one of the main killers for that
organization for the New Mexican Mafia
right and I didn't know it and I was
dealing with damn feet for a couple of
years and when I took the ecstasy over
the first time they were they called me
back this everyone our pills come on
best friend so it was two years later I
was because the Mexican American guy who
protected from the police he became one
of my protectors and I took him over to
his brother's house a couple years later
whole street was blacked out police were
out with the light ones directing
traffic and we know we were like free to
come early we'd have been part of the
raid the feds had raided them and it was
headline news showed of all the pictures
New Mexican Mafia most violent dangerous
criminalized organization Arizona
murder-for-hire tried to assassinate the
head of the prison system assassinated
carps witnesses trying to sass innate
Georg's all this all this kind of smile
I didn't even know at all that night how
are you so ignorant to that how did you
well I knew they were heavy because of
the rocket-propelled grenade launcher
but I did not know they were called the
New Mexico man yeah yeah so people knew
I was associated with them and then that
got me protection and so there were a
lot of there wasn't just one gang in
this area a lot of rival gangs the drugs
business is split in Arizona between the
Mexican American gang which is the New
Mexican Mafia who are born in America
and the Mexican gangs out of Mexico and
they're actually at war with each other
generally especially in the prison
system because the coke and the drugs
comes in across the border Arizona's on
the border so a lot of it comes massive
money muscle money being made and then
you got the Aryan Brotherhood
you got the biker gangs who like
manufacture a crystal meth on a smaller
scale than the Mexico the biker gangs
are the ones who do meth a lot on there
yeah yeah so they're also white
supremacist yes right yeah
checking yeah and so you're in with
these guys without just check these guys
this poor dead giveaway usually your
white supremacist okay just check it and
so you're in with these guys at this
point yeah and it's not like you can
sort of go I'd rather go with them not
once you're in once you're in you're in
is that right yeah once you're in you're
in a minority though I didn't fully
understand the magnitude of that yet
right as someone who's just getting
started in the XE business now you might
stand out a little bit in a mexican
group yeah yeah um do you were you the
only white guy there I didn't hang out
with them
I was just go on deliver my e I'll get
some weed off him from a mate and guys
in in Arkansas in Arizona in Arizona I'm
miss sure that you're a suit-and-tie
multi-millionaire for some reason you're
agreed as ended up will you mix them
with people like that one you who you
were done you were safe you were sound
you had enough money and lastly the rest
of your life just keep going away or or
and because you want to go down this
road you're now getting involved in
people who could kill you without
thinking not even given a [__] any
moment the sex and drugs was way too
exciting for me do you know do is we can
just clip that there because that's it
that's enough for me I understand
yes made at the understand no I love in
the 20s yeah testosterone going crazy
and but you see you went from drugs you
went from the stock mop stock market to
drugs how did that happen as a drug user
as a teenager in the rave scene in this
country transferred that over to America
as a precise participant originally in
the rave scene but then I saw the
business first i fry race racing similar
barrel is it different sort of America
what happens is if something breaks out
in Europe it comes in on the coast side
so I come into New York come into LA and
it filters in slowly and sometimes it
never gets to the heartland so it was
behind a few years you know
I got in with the people who you know
the progenitors of that scene and I
became what was called the Bank of
England to them had all this money and I
was financing the parties and I was
financing clothing stores music clothes
you're also quite authentic in a sense
because you you came from the rave scene
in England yeah you knew all about it
you know about all the big DJ's you know
but all the big music all these tapes
and everyone all these flyers you're
really authentic knows all the time
could I create it in Arizona I was part
of the recreation of it yeah and but at
that time you're also still trading on
the stock market well I went from being
a stockbroker to quit in that and get in
full-time into the rave scene and doing
some internet trading for myself during
the dot-com bubble and are you making
money from the rave scene as well oh god
yeah I was making a lot you know if you
bring in forty thousand pills here's how
it works if you're the guy who's
wholesaling it that's a lot you will
front them out to your guys to the each
faction that say eight dollars a pill to
ten dollars a pill and then the head of
the faction he had given to his dealers
at like 15 and then the dealer's ago I
saw them in the clothes for 20 to 30
doubling and so ye and then how much do
you see that I'm seeing whatever I pay
say let's say my talk cost to the
Holland is like three dollars a pill I'm
getting ten so I get seven times forty
thousand yeah which is a good return
280,000 does it yeah yeah but then you
got our people gonna get jacked
and you got your legal expenses and you
and all that kind of thing as well so
okay eetz into it that's and so at that
point you have a group of how many of
these guys who are running loads of
dealers for you I say I've got about 20
fractions okay yeah I thought if you're
getting yes you're saying one faction
would do one run for you not necessarily
the fact that runners were separate from
the factions yeah I have specific people
who were mules how are you getting them
in there and swallowing the pills
bringing them in many cases what
we never called I didn't know before
9/11 you could do this you could get on
a plane
yeah and just throw pills into
pillowcases put me in your luggage off
you wanted to be more secure computer
tower screwed a pills into the tower
yeah and then what you have to do it
through a clever route if you send
someone to Holland from Phoenix and they
get on a plane dude isn't coming back
back
laminate busted so I had legal advice
didn't I so the lawyer said best thing
to do was have your people fly out there
and then go over by train to like France
or Germany right get her France to
Mexico City get a flight from Mexico
City to Hermosillo which is near Tijuana
which is where I've got met my ex
Mexican operations based in that state
rocky point I had property in Rocky
Point on the coaster in Mexico and then
we transfer the pills then over to other
smugglers who bring them over the
Arizona border right it helps if there's
something like spring break because it's
spring break all the students are down
the borders over the traumas constantly
add borås overwhelmed yeah they're not
wanting to hold everyone up searched and
everyone has no idea is that and you
guys can just basically want your aid
once you're in Arizona you're absolutely
fine yeah yeah so how'd people who
specialized in smuggling as well yeah
there's so many questions on there I
want to know you know I do have memories
where specific nights where you you you
must have felt like you were king of the
[__] world like can you remember
those highs I mean I know things got
pretty low after this book you don't
memorize no but yeah you must have had
nights where you felt like the [__]
ecstasy version of Scarface for Christ's
sake yeah like I'd hire these rooms at
the Hilton in Scottsdale that were like
massive they had like a studio cover DJ
in her almost like big room and people
roller skating around and doing all with
[__] there was to me was the late 90s
there was two wings there was two wings
on either side with jacuzzis in them and
like a mansion at this a bisexual wife
so we were dead on and she's buying all
her friends she's inviting friends
gornstein
not only that I had a maid and we call
her the head of the department of thanks
and this is this this girl Sally white
we'll call her whatever we went web a
party she would be like oh I can nail
any girl before you guys and I allow
them back to the after partying will be
doing back triangles and all this kind
of stuff and it was just sailed
connection free love sin and so law
restrictions those parties in the hill I
mean how'd you get away with that in
Hilton but just like the best amount of
money you spend a way that that's
expected it there's five hundreds it's a
night and I just pay for two nights we'd
be so high we might keep it going I just
I just roller skate roll the boot up to
the reception with my shades on is
another five hundred for another day and
conspicuous in that pocket Elmo because
that that area doesn't strike me as sort
of like the biggest you know not
everyone's a raver in that area yeah I
knew where the heat was the heat was on
me in Tempe was not in Scottsdale so I
was like an eccentric English wealthy
dude right stop market with Commerce
story because you had clean money as
they call it it's money that wasn't
earned by the glamorize that let me give
you another situation I got in Wednesday
party one time got so high put my head
through a plaster board wall almost
misses missed the nine inch nail that
could be gone into my school mates took
me home can't remember but woke up the
next day covered in puke puke all over
the carpet bed it's stained the carpet I
call a carpet cleaner
comes out of his specialty chemicals to
get this thing out he's trying to get
rid of it he's looking at me and he's
shake anything like Sean whatever
chemicals you had in your body you're so
strong I can't get them out of your
carpet
so yeah I'm lucky I'm still alive and
obviously we're gonna go and uh what
happened afterwards but you don't take
drugs anymore you know don't even drink
yeah you often find people who've gone
to that extreme don't even drink after
they've come out with all the dope I
mean because drink is seen to be
harmless by comparison that is what I'm
saying but they often don't feel the
need for anything once you've been to
that extreme chill I'm saying I had to
go deep inside myself and address the
root causes of why I had taken drugs in
the first place in prison and the
therapist helped me understand it
started out with me self-medicating for
PTSD from almost getting beat to death
by the drunks I don't understand any of
that and I just exacerbated my own
problem by just get into these drug Club
drug cocktails by the end of it I was on
crystal meth ketamine GHB ecstasy JH
Bailey's are dissertate but it just
makes you a [__] you're just you're
not even aware of anything like well you
can you can conk out on it but I did it
in a way that I learnt how to get the
right dose and I really enjoyed GHB and
most after ecstasy I'm saying yeah yes
eh gamma hydroxide buta mace
bodybuilders suck it because it relaxed
them my dad's a bodybuilder yeah there
you go
but it got made illegal after someone
drank it and I think they mixed it with
alcohol and then they ran over a cop
right so it became this illegal thing
you could get from the gay bars then
because it relaxed you so much it
loosened the sphincter and it was
perfect for anal sex right so I had the
muscle boys out the gay bars supply me
the GHB yeah and so you are you've got
it surrounded by drugs CERN about people
who are quite relying on you and imagine
all these people are coming to you for
to deal drugs to go for all the big
parties you're the number one guy in
town basically
yeah when you were watching wolf of Wall
Street just because we're not at the
point where things went tits up but it
does go pretty bad yeah were you
watching the wolf of Wall Street
thinking yourself [__] me this is
bringing back some memories yes smile
and dial
we have to stand up and pace while we're
on the phones with its long telephone
extension cords you're only as big as
your numbers are out on a month if your
Commission's only the top of this board
you need to stop calling your girl fat
stop calling your wives or if you're not
calling people over brokers are calling
your people oh yeah it was like you know
boot camp basically and it was very
competitive very precious [__] yeah so
what I find unusually is putting
yourself someone who's quite anxious
somebody's quite socially awkward in
that environment because of my greed to
make a million overrode that social
anxiety because I was on the phone I
wasn't really face to face with people
saying yeah yeah it's almost like it's
not real it's really a great coping
mechanism you had a lot of ways to get
around your anxieties what you and I
complete when someone first sent me 10
grand over a phone call after phone call
through the mail I was later looking
back do you feel like if that young lad
who had the insecurities and anxiety I'd
have had therapy then before you started
using drugs do you think you might never
have gone down the treu group because
those things could have influenced me
and sent me on a different path my drugs
education back then was a video of an
egg frying in a pan and I'm saying this
is your drug this is your brain on drugs
yeah so yeah so I didn't I went out to a
cactus II had the time of my life aw
yeah this is cool I didn't see what
comes out you down that road you love
boiling that agate up so so where did it
all go wrong and at the point all right
I'm out a lovely woman couple years
before the SWAT team came in about a
year in she taught me our dealing she
said this is so dangerous for us I want
you to stop and cut I loved it so much I
stopped at dealing before I got away
with it did you get away from that kind
of thing we just go right stop there see
ya what happened was my whole business
collapsed with the stock market collapse
after the.com bubble so the bubble burst
in this financially yeah I was plummeted
and I was I was pulling away from it but
I couldn't stop going out on the weekend
with my mates my best mate was over
there wild man from my hometown
it was hardcore and I called the stop
going out of him on the weekends and
getting high he's from England yeah he's
from witness as well
he's like 25 style he's knows he's quite
an obvious fists a covered beef Maxwell
the fights he said he he was a good man
to get arrested with let's put it this
way and I thought I'd go away with it
you know if the catch me now there's no
drugs or anything but I was naive to
what's called the statute of limitations
all it takes is someone within seven
year period to say to the police this
guy saw me drugs and they've got you
really yeah so turn witness witnesses
came forward and that was the case and
it was they wiretap dose and then he
goes and the police are asking people
did this guy say yeah you'd stop dealing
drugs by this point yeah but were the
mud financially did you still have
people on payroll and they know I was
down I was down to six figures at this
point right I'd blast it through
everything and how many millions do you
reckon three I was giving away like
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
exit pills on the weekends to my friends
just pissing the money away like crazy
getting limo rides for the corner store
and just show it off yeah I can't even
imagine it's Millions yeah do you ever
do you cringe a little bit the way you
used to corn yeah I should have bought
my parents a house in Spain and stuff
like that but I thought it was gonna I
was going to build it back up again I
thought I was a smart in the cops flew
people over put money in their names how
the cops gonna get that but please put a
net Bush Trojan horse in my computer
right so the day I was arrested they
took everything everything yeah comes
the state's
oh yeah war on drugs is a business model
they target wealthy people's if you're
stupid enough to be wealthy and
committing crimes they low and loved if
they open you've got my pension is a
stockbroker everything I mean we could
get out into the whole war on drugs
conversation that's not really part of
your story is it definitely infamous it
so take us to the deer the SWAT team
arrived so I go up get on the computer
and it's like 6:00 7:00 in the morning
I'm putting a trade in and then
I hear this noise on the stairs outside
come in this apartment in Scottsdale and
Bam Bam Bam Bam bang so I'll go through
the door it's blacked out first thing
I'm thinking all right it could be two
things it could be two cops I come
someone who knows my name thinks I've
got money from the drug community he's
come to rob me which one of you thinking
it is which one are you hoping it is at
this point perhaps the latter yes I
could do it up better so I go to the
window police cars everywhere marksman
with rifles my gosh
[__] go through to the bedroom
girlfriend's getting out bed I'm like
what we're gonna do better let but open
the door let them in we get halfway
through the living room boom door just
flies off the hinges bounces against the
wall they all just open up with the guns
then hands don't move get on the ground
I just about crapped myself get down
really fast I'm thinking you know hearts
almost jumps up my chest if they start
shooting my life's over so you get down
fast and then they just crush you and
coffee eventually I was yanked up by the
detective ever learned was my nemesis
from the police paperwork and he's like
you're a big name from the rave scene
English Shawn we've got you you know we
know Lestrade he's gonna justify this
and you're going down basically and at
that point what are you feeling nothing
in [__] everything I've done wrong no
it's caught with me chickens coming back
to me there's no way my karma wasn't
gonna have to be repaid yes but to be
honest I was for the first year pining
to get back to the lifestyle and get
high right I was missing my how big
house missing Maga jeez misses my
sportscar twin-turbo missing my plasma
screen TV all this stuff though I was
still amidst this material character and
it's what my second unit year when I was
pushed to the brink of suicidal insanity
for me to start seeing the needs of all
people helping prisoners and to reflect
on my life and to get going this new
positive direction and so you went to
trial I imagine that was quite easy to
know I didn't go to trial it just going
straight don't go to trial Arizona
because they make an example out of you
because it costs a state
to go to trial like I said justice ism
is a business model they want you to
sign a plea bargain and then just go
over to the prison system to jail is a
conveyor belts of prison system so
ninety-eight percent of the prisoners
sign plea bargains now I was the last
man standing in my case I was on
sentence for 26 months they tried to get
break all my co-defendants down to
snitch against me now over 100 people
only four of them agreed to testify
because we were that close Sammy the
balls case he had 50 similar
co-defendants and I think they all agree
to testify against him now second year
in I'm saying you know I'm not going to
sign a plea bargain and so they think
all right we're going to increase the
pressure on this guy so they move me
from medium-security over to maximum
security well I don't I don't know
anyone it's a lot of murders a lot of
crystal meth chemists am I right in
thinking they used to watch one of your
things before you came and that we used
a really sneaky tactic to get you from
medium to maximum yeah where they
increased the years that you would have
done for a specific reason
a fart was going to get released on bail
I'll fight the case outside my lawyer
said let's try this went to court and
the judge he ends up doubling my bail to
1.5 million which means you if your bail
goes over a million awesome ethical
thatcher AZ that's how they got you yeah
yeah and I'm guessing that judges aren't
particularly kind but it's not like you
were a mass murderer you weren't I was a
non-violent criminal that's done I think
that needs to be remembered like when
you when you sentence someone or give
someone a set bail you're gonna put him
in with the serial killers and you are
not a violent person in any way yeah
you're a different kind of criminal but
you will have had a negative effect on
people's lives through them taking drugs
on drugs those kind of things but you
did directly go out and stab someone and
that's all for violence and violent
charges yeah so I did end up in Supermax
later on through another trick of
prosecutor play [__] me
that was after I got sent this though so
it's oh wait there's there's a medium
high and his Supermax something else our
Supermax
is the most violent dangerous criminals
or housing super match can we go through
the stages that you went through and
when it happened so when you first first
went into a jail yeah what was that
first day like and how did it feel all
right when you first arrested you go
into a processing sequence of cells
called the horseshoe and basically this
is the new arrestees and you're in these
cells for days you don't know what they
is all you can feel is the heat rise in
the heat falling and you're crammed in
sardines like 40 50 people fights
breaking out there's blood on the walls
guards are running in grabbing people
people acting up on drugs if you really
act up the guards grab you out and put
you in a restraint chair it looks like a
medieval torture device it's like tool
it back they strap you in and they put a
spit hood on your head and this people
just out there in these chairs just
howling and whining sounds like
something off a horror film
yeah it's hardly was and then you get to
see the judge and then I got sent over
to medium security in the beginning
which is completely gang and drug
infested so as soon as I get to my part
for skinhead dudes suave ease on them we
need we want a world of unicel batter
and you know you can't say no because
because you look like their type of
recruit is that why no cuz I'm white and
everyone who's white has to do this
whatever race you are one of the racial
gangs is going to do this is for rain
and whites blacks Mexicans
mexican-americans so the neo-nazi Aryan
Brotherhood gang control the white race
I'm not I don't know this yet but I just
got do what they say so I going to sell
and alike
what are you charges and I've read
machardie some little prints out but
it's all in legalese don't understand it
setup I've got my charge but I'm not
sure what it means like what do you mean
you don't know what it means you would
show mo you would show mo what's that
don't watch I was even right so I'm
digging my grave
it's a child molester right so they've
got me up the wall about to smash me and
I'll make you things worse because I
don't know how to behave in a prison or
what a chomo is Oh watch your eyes yeah
I'm gonna pull up my chart see I'm like
lot lot so they look at it and they see
I've got drug charges they see my Bailey
$750,000 and they love that
yeah they're like who did you kill I was
officials often you're an important
person instantly with those numbers
that's why it saved me they saved my ass
right now and then and nearly everyone
in prison is in because of drugs
committing crimes on drugs positive for
drugs just literally all druggie so they
accepted me then yeah
they accepted me but lonely want nacho
more yeah but one of myself one of the
new guys who came in with me was a
suspected Chama
[__] me yeah so the next day they're
asking me about him and I'm like I don't
know about him I don't know [__] about
him so the next day I hear somebody
getting beat in this in the shower area
and it's the skinhead gang the one that
questioned me and they leave this guy
know like what he's still whimpering in
a pool of blood and then this big guy
grabbed out your size he's got tattoos
cobwebs on his neck he's like how come
we can still hear him and the head of
the skinheads he's like are we smashed
him good dog little bit guys in there
not good enough so he goes in and it's
just like he's trying to crack this
guy's head open like it's a coconut just
crack crack crack and the guy looks dead
and a guard that's a security walk and
he gets carried out on a stretcher and
there's not just blood coming out he's
had this like yellow fluid like brain
stuff coming out of his head it was
there every day then there was violence
let's get used to the sounds a heads
getting bashed against the toilets
bodies getting thrown around people
getting carried on stretchers like that
so I want suspected child molester they
wait until the guard that the security
walks they got the most amount of time
possible with him so watching him here
he came out covered in blood from head
to toes what thought managed to get down
the stairs knocked on the windows of the
guards and the open the door and he just
he just collapsed
I saw it was a mentally ill old man
wouldn't stop rambling so the gangs
fought I will shut him up I was walking
past them it was blood just squirting
out in the back of his head just to
clarify you sent me some video clips or
you came yeah and said just so you can
see what I'm gonna be talking about
tomorrow here are some of the jailed
footage that's on YouTube I'll try and
have it put over some of the podcast but
you know it might be disturbing
so you might want to look away have some
of the other pockets had the reason
there are CCTV footage of gun violence
going on where people are just being
allowed to murder each other in the
prison cell and only 20 30 minutes later
dude the guards come in after the lads
being lying there dead for god knows how
long and actually have a look and
obviously the guys know about it not
only know I've got videos on my youtube
channel off the guards murdering
prisoners yeah
mentally ill prisoners there was one
that really [__] me up was the ones
that you let you centers with a soldier
yeah he was a US soldier had been
arrested for having an argument in a car
park yeah which you know could happen
anyone he gets drugged in and for
whatever reason he's not taking any
other [__] and he gets a it seems to be
a bit of a verbal argument between him
and the prison gods yeah and they just
choked him out tears at him to death and
just like literally beat the [__] out
left him there in a Cell on his own and
I'm watching this footage I'm [__]
out in your lap he's not moving and they
go back in and they've got to try a
[__] resuscitate and man he's gone
and it's like you're resuscitating him
you [__] did it to him
you [__] killed him they killed a
blind man Brian Crenshaw he failed to
produce his ID for the evening means
he's blind they beat him god severe
internal injuries went to coma if the
other [__] gods for the president it
makes you [__] wonder like Donna
scott norburg mentally ill man on the
neighborhood that they brought him in
started beating him electrocuting him
with Tasers a female guard tried to stop
it stop beating him his faces turn blue
he pushed her off they kept beating him
the prisoner started yelling why are you
still beating him he's already dead hmm
it turned blue and everything and if
they still beat misty he was already
dead and some of those guards would end
that the family members because it's on
CCTV sued to jail and got compensation
and and and the bosses to jail what do
you guys think he'd hits at this some of
the guards who have held responsible in
federal court for those those deaths he
promoted them yeah yeah promotions and
pay rises [__] me yeah if this is where
obviously England in America if
massively because if that happened in
England well you'd hope and you'd think
that usually the guy in charge would be
instantly dismissed and sucked in they
would put a new face in his position
yeah it is there is something funny of
not funny if there is something unusual
about jail isn't it I mean everyone goes
back to the you know the social
scientist who made all the people act
out the jail or some people the
prisoners some people the guards
yeah Milgram's yeah it's it it it's not
like that's not the end goal of a jail
is it but for some reason that happens
in what in theory resource to
rehabilitate people well I mean in
theory I mean it very base it's supposed
to keep the people who have done bad
things apart from people have done good
things but for some reason what's
happened in the American prison system
the worry is it clapping in England as
well if the if people continue to go
down this route is that it's corrupted
as a system and now it's doing the
opposite voice causes money and you hit
it on the head
basically prisons were designed and the
police were started by Robert Peel out
of London to stop person a her in person
being murder robbery rape that's how
crime has been delight defined for
millennia yeah
drug laws were introduced in the last
century and the private prisons were
introduced and this gave us like you
know fifty thousand dollars a year of
taxpayers money per prisoner who are the
easiest people to arrest to fill our
prisons or to maximize our profits young
people with weed yeah almost a million
arrests a year young people revered not
dealers possession black people
especially the racism is off the scale
and women became the fastest growing
prison population women don't belong in
prison but because of drug laws they did
so that's that's what we've had in
America and that's why America's got one
in a hundred adults in prison one in
20-something adult black guys are in
prison more than were held under slavery
before slavery was abolished if you
include probation and parole me yeah
because I was listening to podcast the
other day actually after we'd spoken
about drugs with a couple of guests in a
row and they were talking about how drug
laws I mean this ties in some lawyers in
there are also made by certain people
who want to keep certain factions be the
ones when Chinese pill wheel spun and or
when Chinese people were first in LA
Chinese people their community did
certain kinds of drugs so the people in
LA made those illegal so they were
selling the jobs during economic
downturns
less targeted Chinese with opium laws
that's how drugs loss started in
California yeah exactly when the federal
level it came about in the early 1900s
and now it was to protect the banks who
had invested in pharmaceuticals plastics
oil and all these industries that were
competing against hemp so they said
let's change the name of hemp to
marijuana this Mexican will harness the
racism and let's start putting black
people and Mexicans and principles they
used to use hemp for all sorts of things
like thousands of it's actually a really
great yeah multi-purpose tool isn't it
really his podcast isn't sponsored by
him like tents out of it and clothes out
of it and all sorts of things I mean a
racist drug czar called Harry Anslinger
basically went to the United Nations
this was a guy who was telling everybody
black men on cocaine or marijuana on a
rape every white woman in sight the main
reason for making these drugs illegal is
its effect on the degenerate races yeah
he went to the United Nations and said
every country in the world is signing on
for this or else America is not going to
trade with you that's why the world's
got all these drug laws because the war
on drugs because of America this comes
from this drug czar this racist drug sir
and now I think I mean it's very
difficult at the time to socially break
things down like the war on drugs and
those sort of things because it was
packaged up as a really good social
thing and looking back now in retrospect
all that reefer madness stood that yeah
your killer you lacked myrrh the
appearance if you smoked underneath but
at the time people painted this as you
know it's wrong you know we need to get
rid of this from our society and the war
on drugs will make us a good Society
what was the racism was such that they
steeped it in that and that's how they
sold it they said look the cops the
media type in at the time William
Randolph Hearst
he put articles out saying a black man
on cocaine has superhuman strength yeah
and if you shoot him a cop tried to
shoot a black man in the heart with a
normal bullet and he didn't die because
he had this superhuman strength on
cocaine the police got so stirred all
across America they demanded higher
caliber bullets to kill black men on
cocaine with superhuman strength it's
[__] insane this yeah it makes you
think why I mean obviously we know why
now that they're Rickon and so much
money but they have to redress these
laws because if they were passed on that
basis
it's laughable as well that's why weed
has been decriminalized in America
because Obama's maintained it as a
Schedule one substance more harmful than
cocaine and as harmful as heroin with no
medicinal value because he's protecting
these corporate interests is it the
state left I run a voted to make it
legal that's that's the people and so
obviously the government at this point
they aren't really in control of the
situation are they well the government
represents that who's got the most money
look who's putting up the money to keep
the drug laws going it's the tobacco
companies the farmers colonies
if serious books if if we've got
legalized for example how many people
would drink less alcohol smoke less
tobacco and and in general the medical
companies who are trying to give out
painkillers and all of that they would
suffer as well because we'd would target
so many of those people its moral
relativism what gives the cops and the
judges and the prosecutors you're
hardcore pisshead some what I've seen
the right a lot kids up there smoking
weed so getting back to the prison
conditions because I know you've talked
about them before and I think it'd be
great hear about that yeah how bad were
the prisons there because I know they've
got what some of the worst reputation
and wellness the worst office is the
rape there's the raping prison rape is
so common in America you have to go to a
rape class so learn how not to get raped
right so basically you go to this class
and you watch a video and they show
predators in the dayroom
and the young people come in and some of
the young people take sweets from the
Predators and some don't and it knows
we're in debt they have to repay with
sexual favors and the conclusion of the
video was to start rape in prisons it's
got to be reported to the police but one
of the gang rules is which they explain
to you when you come in if you report
anything you're a snitch yeah it's Kos
kill on sight for snitches so you can't
report anything so right after we went
this class a young mentally ill prisoner
was gang-raped and nobody reported a
thing now the most horrific rape story I
heard was from a friend of mine a
transgender friend of call Xena
six and a half foot charismatic when
Xena first came in
she wasn't this [__] I'm gonna say she
because it's disrespectful to call trans
prisoners he zina believe she's a woman
trapped in a man's body
right when she first came in she was big
clicked up with the gang that collect
that blood in blood out was was
brutalized by them when they'd used a
rope so I said I said to zina what
happened I said the first time was a
gang rape they beat me unconscious shove
things inside my body while I was
unconscious and raped me while I was
unconscious I said how do you know that
they were raping you if you were
unconscious and she said when she went
the toilet afterward she could tell by
what came out yeah I said well what did
they stick inside your body a broomstick
so after the rape she sat in an SL
waiting for the scars to go away because
you can't report it like I said it's
snitches kill on sight she got moved to
another yard got used as a prostitute
and it happened again and I said well
you know how did you end up stopping
this and she said I started ton and I
don't curve or live or die anymore I
started fighting back when I stood up
for myself I was winning the fights and
they left me alone after that but she
hadn't told me the truth so zina I come
up with an idea and the next two times
the gang came to rape zina first member
of the gang to put his hand on Xena Xena
plucked his eyeball out so it was
dangling from the optic nerve right yes
after doing that twice they left Zenor
alone but they moved on to some of her
friends
one of her friends the gang raped him
took a light bulb shoved it in his
backside played a game to see who could
break it the first while it was in this
guy's ass that prisoner and committed
suicide afterwards another one they got
a shovel from the work crew they held
him down they cut his head off and when
his head was finally off they positioned
it in an area of the prison where the
rival gangs would see it right to make
the point they were the most violent and
ruthless out of all the gangs and that
was the Aryan Brotherhood prison gang
the neo-nazis
they did that today today another one
back to someone else have been Athena's
friends someone Xena's friends another
one of Xena's friends was kicked
repeatedly so hard in the in the man
parts
it crushed his testicles and did
something to his earlier down here
I was the spleen or something like that
and his bits had to be removed another
one they snapped a broomstick shoved it
in his ass and when they removed it it
left splinters in his stomach right and
so on and so on it's the things I heard
just blew my mind that's why I started
writing these stories down and putting
him on the Internet as this blog John's
jail Journal which it became a bridge to
the prisoners so that they started to
get pen pals and books and stuff like
that because the world didn't have no
idea what was going on and so these are
horrific stories which are dehumanizing
so they sound like they're things that
are done to people who are objects and
not people and that's part of the way
that prison makes people feel now and
again it sort of goes against what you
were saying about it that being a
rehabilitation you can't really get
rehabilitated from being raped and there
are people who are going to be in there
as well admit who are psychopaths on the
you know if you like the very nature of
imprisonment hood off yeah yeah I mean
how now this is where it's sort of
interesting for me is because you're
sitting here now relatively normal guy
and obviously you know you tell your
story very openly hmm how did you get
through that and what was your date day
like input all right I had someone my
mates were arrested with me we're just
gonna show you a photo of wild man and
these were some of my bouncers from the
rave scene and right seeing you had
friends inside like I said wild man was
is 25 stole his Nell just pointing in a
funny direction which I'm just gonna
roll all the scars and his so forgot the
comer on there Phil the scars on his
face a wild man that's the wild man yeah
yeah he's a handyman to get arrested
with I mean he started strain and it's
live a very similar relationship Brian
and I started treating these fighting
skills on nightclub bouncers as a
teenager and he got the [__] beat out of
me look like it's true and it hit him at
one point they think I just that's the
way he was and um and so he obviously
white so he's part of the Aryan
when he showed up in the prison and they
came to question him the guy from the
Aryan Brotherhood came to question him
he just knocked him out and the Aryan
Brotherhood start ripping on him saying
we're gonna figure out who you are and
they came back and said we know you are
and we
give you a job that guy's job you
knocked out to run this building because
they worked out because he's a hard case
you said that the general conditions in
the prison as well were disturbing to
say that Lee said cockroaches are lower
in the middle of the night and that when
I got moved from medium security I was a
maximum security when I first got into
that cell it was about 2:00 in the
morning and it was dark with some light
slanting him from the day room first
thing I see this guy asleep on a top
bunk
the high school there's only two bunks
in my time security is less crowded why
is he on the top bunk because where I
come from people fight over the bottom
bunk so I walk in a little bit I start
to sense stuff on movement like on the
wall and the ceiling something dropped
off the wall but stuff me oh [__] what's
going on here so I put my face right up
to the wall and it's just absolutely
covered in cockroaches hmm and I got
used to the violence by now but living
with these guys have on the hardest
parts for me I mean what's it like and
you had to sleep in that room an ace at
night is locked down
10:00 is lights out so in locked out all
you got eating yourself and the guards
turned the lights out at 10:00 and they
start lining up in the cracks in the
walls before lights out they know when
the lights are about to go out to like
an army waiting to invade so as soon as
your lights go out they go like this
all over the walls and the ceiling just
everywhere so I learned anyway what you
got to do is you got a rap sheet around
you and leave a breathing hole so you
like The Mummy which keeps my for you
but the sheet traps the heat to your
body
it's almost 50 degrees in the summer
there's hardly any air coming in it's
like a concrete oven so be so because of
that you've got all these bleeding and
itching skin infections and bed sores it
looked like I spilt battery acid on my
body at one point and you got this itch
you trying it yourself but cause you're
sweating every day your skin's soggy and
clumps of your skin just come off under
your nails so you've got this this sheet
around you to keep the cockroaches off
you
but then the itchiness kicks in and it's
so hard then with the itchy nose to keep
this sheet on you just can't do it don't
it just from the sheet off you let them
crawl on you yeah so they stick tickle
your feet your legs to this day if
anyone tickles my hands I flinch
walk-up song light some particular man's
they got on your face hang on your mouth
nose they really love going in your ears
because the your wax is like money -
yeah yeah even if I win effect if I like
wash my ear out with a little cloth and
put it down it beyond the cloth like at
the at the wax I got to learn the habits
of cockroaches very well they were my
best self it's required quite well once
I once I don't do my [__] head unless
it's tried to get used to discussing a
look I don't there we were doing
cockroach races gambling on the winner
they're not they're not injure us are
they all the way W yeah we just want
love and affection really like I need
any paths it's really just a it's really
just a really annoying and really
upsetting to have that all night I like
Paloma smells really on after two or
three nights of no sleep you start to
hear voices and see imaginary
cockroaches so I wrote out a written
request to the jail and they put me on
some kind of medication to get to sleep
well yeah that's a girl in the end but
let's go let's get back to your
day-to-day so you spent your day today
around this guy they just so Oh world
man yeah yeah a mad well mum protecting
me my Mexican American guy make New
Mexican really make some Africa he
wasn't arrested with us on that date so
he never ended up in it with me but I've
got some other bouncers in there with me
a guy calls that he was obvious it was
like six foot seven six four eight
something like that but you can't be
around those guys all the time correct
correct or water travels very fast about
who is who in the community like that
right so we were one of the biggest
groups in the room and jail the story
had been in the news in the newspaper
front page cover story all our pictures
of the heads of the criminal
organizations of the prisons were seen
this and when we went to church and did
our meetings together we're all giving
each other hugs people paying attention
yeah so you know I'm not a big tough guy
I mean look at the size of me I could
have been played and I would have been
annihilated if I hadn't gotten over my
bouncers like wow but because I had them
protecting me I didn't get attacked that
many times right and but you did get it
oh yeah everyone gets a sack you don't
have to fall prison experience unless
you get back okay they're just not doing
it right yeah and so was that fairly
early on and always this after I got
separated from my guys after got
sentenced I was facing 200 years they
said it
spoke on the phone and carried a tent
and five to ten years out 20 plus
charges so you're not getting out of
that my parents remark you to the house
to come on 100 grand cuz in America
you've sentences determined by who your
lawyer is now much money you've got got
it down to nine and a half signed a plea
bargain go over to the prison system now
before I get attacked the prosecutor
she's played loads of dirty tricks on me
from I'm a man room an because I'm not
refusing to cooperate and in the end she
accidentally puts my prison sentence
down not as nine and a half years but as
34 years to the prison system
so I'm then classified as the most
highest level of security fast tracked
as a super maximum-security prison in
Florence Arizona yet my cellmate my
neighbor is a serial killer
my cellmate he's got a satanic inverted
pentagram tattooed on his forehead and
for murder part of a course that's
drinking blood and eating human body
plants and yet I just learned that it's
all later
right what he was very nice to me you
just read a book about Leonardo a tasty
it's just read a book about Leonardo da
Vinci and he gave me and we discussed
there and never had any problems with
him it's not free and four months for me
to get sorted out and go to medium Scott
you what it should have been in the
first place I'm hoping these guys will
be a bit softer I have to Supermax
guards decided to play a prank on me put
me in with Anna Soria those YouTube
pranks this isn't on YouTube they're
fake pranks all the time yeah this is
this is real what's mean we have a notes
on audio serial home invade that torture
they really got a guy who's whose
kidnapping drug dealers and his favorite
method authorities taking hammers to the
kneecap know you've got a hope at that
point that because you're in his home
with him that he won't wanna invade you
because that's fine you just get the
next all that's a real home invasion I
know we are making jokes panelist at
this point harrowing this is one of the
worst points now for me is when he says
to me the night I move in I've got a
padlock in a sock I can smash your
brains emotionally I could kill you at
everyone I've got no one there no they
don't know me properly yet
I freaking [__] what I'm gonna do I'm
not a big tough guy this is this is big
tatted up guy he wants to be him with an
old con of fish it doesn't want a fresh
fish like me which is what he's viewing
me as why didn't you want a fresh fish I
eat most 90% the prisoners are shooting
up heroin and he's running an illegal
tattoo shop out of his cell he wants
someone like in that do what he wants
exactly which is understandable and I'm
all right you know I'll do is read and
write I don't ever know the guy really
he doesn't like that so he doesn't
attack me directly because he's just
been on for holding a kangaroo court on
a sex offender who he met in a while in
transit in some prison cell somewhere
and he kidnapped this guy they held him
and stabbed him a lot of times and he
threatened to pop eyeballs out and eat
him if anyone snitch to him so he's just
been all this trouble he's just got back
to his cell he doesn't want to tapped me
directly so we go it sees me 20-plus
Stone California bikers a member of the
Aryan Brotherhood gang to attack me just
where my mom and dad have come to visit
me for Christmas they're just flown
5,000 miles just to spoil it just to be
snide yeah so I'm walking to this visit
happy as can be
visits and mail are gold in prison it's
what you look forward to big guy sneaks
up behind me kidney punches me I've not
done karate at this point or anything at
all to respond properly so this guy
Niall AIT's me knocked me down and
fortunately someone yelled guard was
coming so the damage wasn't too much but
he smashed my back up real good enough
to for my mom to notice when I got to
the visit she's like what's wrong with
you and I can't say mom's always a
nervous breakdown of my situation got a
protector so in the end when I got back
to the cell my cell mate he's getting
high on heroin AM F and acting crazy
towards me most young people coming in
WestEd for weed but they graduates a
habit heroin into prison yeah and he's
like acting crazy and he's showing me
the pen like he's gonna smash my skull
in with I got sauce good it was the only
time a call for outside help I took a
risk here because I didn't want to get
be marked as a snitch call my family
said look can you put a call into the
British Embassy see if they'll call the
prison and get me moved because I think
this guy's gonna try and kill me but
when they call the prison they can say
anything I've said that will get him in
trouble because that will make me a
snitch Kos kill on sight everyone's
gonna want to kill me
fortunately embassy handled it
appropriately or was moved and I didn't
get in trouble because he found that he
said he came running down the stairs
he's like I'm gonna [__] kill you if
I'm finding out right now what's been
said if you've said anything that's
gonna get me in trouble you're dead and
even if they move me off this yard the
other guys are gonna kill you for being
a snitch I'm like I haven't said
anything I stand my ground and be in a
Cell down here you find out whatever you
find out all I said was we didn't get
along and I want to be moved well that's
what's that's all they said that we
didn't get along so he found out and
there was no combat from him he was
fried batteries at me for a couple weeks
afterwards until he found all this out
and then I know my new you my new
cellmate who came in I got really lucky
that just goes nicely my Walkman
as much as people came out the blue to
harm me people came out the blue to help
me my new cellmate
I just called from Super Max and his
cellmate in Super Max had been a
gangster I'd done some business with
called gangster Tom in the rave scene
and last thing he said to this guy
before he went to the prison system this
is a prison system of 60,000 people what
was the chances of this he said if you
meet an English dude called English
Shawn look out for him he's a good dude
I did business with him on the streets
and this guy ends up my sell me that's
[__] lucky yeah and then he says to
me right I don't I don't know what's
going through his head at the time he's
not explained he's looking out for me he
says to me I'm gonna introduce you to
someone who wanted to play chess with
and you knew if I met this guy this guy
was gonna protect me didn't tell me this
so he says I said to who do you want me
to place yes with all this guy called to
town he's an old-timer
I'm like well what's he in for mass
murder he's doing over 140 years old on
a minute do I really want to play chess
with this guy because you might want to
kill me if I beat him he I don't know if
they can make that out there but yeah
this is to talk as to Tony's so to
Tony's why did the call him to tourists
you know she's twice the man of any one
to Tony's right Wow - Tony's were
whacked in LA and - Tony's all school
Matthew don't hurt kids you don't hurt
women from the Bonanno crime family Joe
Bonanno his boss was one of the guys who
inspired the Godfather
the two whackers one of the workers was
Charlie batts Battaglia it was to Tony's
boss as he was rising up but eventually
to Tony's became more powerful than
Battaglia after he did some wax and he
was on drugs and he met Battaglia at a
restaurant with his crime partner Sal
Spinelli and as he turns the tables on
burr tackle he threatens him
Battaglia backs down because he see two
Tony's has gone a bit local on the drugs
and he's dangerous
and afterwards Sal Spinelli turns to two
attorneys and said when when you
threaten Battaglia the only back down I
could see the spirits of the to Tony's
over the table right attack they've
killed one of its own yeah so I don't
know any this I made same play chess
with him it's come no it's like uncle
Jun he's got the accent from The
Sopranos yeah comes down he hears max
you can see I'm nervous you know I'm
crapping it mass murder on a 40 plus
years are years max and he's like have
you ever had seen accomplished with the
Beatles
it says how much he likes the Beatles he
puts me at ease we play the game of
chess throughout the game of chess he's
speaking his mind I'm gonna do this
shall do it out by the bank by the bank
and I'm thinking I'm just gonna beat him
because he's speaking his mind I'm not
gonna play any games because this guy's
gonna see through this if I slow play it
so beat him he says at the end he says
how did you beat me so fast but I don't
know but he's testing me and he said I
said cuz you spoke your mind from it you
wouldn't show someone yeah you hand in a
game of cards would ya he said Sean on
the road of life I've had to become a
quick judge of characters to stay alive
I like you I feel you're an honest
person would you be willing to write my
life story and cause I've been a because
I'm a blogger they've been in the news
he already knew what was a writer and he
was waiting for someone to come along so
I started to sneak into his cell every
day I wasn't allowed in he's got
prisoners station looking for guards and
I became his official biographer so
whenever
prisoners came in and the respect he's
robbed enough you know he's introducing
me to them as if he's not the respect
he's rubbing off on to me and love and
that as well and he's loving as well as
he feels Peschel now who's got a
biographer yeah many people have a
biographer
so you got to find a way to fit in in
prison I've got these prison survival
advice videos out there on YouTube and
one of them is if you're not a big tough
guy lay low find out who's who and make
friends with the right people at the
teutonic because you make thing when
these big tattooed guys come up to you
they're running it what the night it's
probably some little oil manager and his
stripes up in some cell like to Tommy's
mm-hmm that's interesting because we
obviously we had we had an heiress on
the podcast as well and he was obviously
talking about his time now he's I
imagine death row is very a whole other
kind of prison yeah you know you're
gonna die so there's a whole different
set of circumstances there but he was
talking about how he used to play games
on some of these guys sort of have unter
with them and that sort of thing
yeah used to play chess with them and
[__] with them and [__] with them
through the chess yeah I'm guessing you
didn't have the same sort of experience
you didn't want to [__] with people you
didn't want to mess with people in there
are people who are messing with people
and where people are getting messed with
I was born there getting messed with
side of it right I'm not trying to cause
waves I'm laying low I'm turning this
into the educational opportunity of a
lifetime right and reading read over a
thousand books and just on the six years
a lot of the original text in philosophy
in psychology and that all helped me
become you know change my ways and then
the whole time I'm assuming you stayed
away from the drugs even other strokes
in the prison I saw the horror of what
drug use led to in the business system
the road of drug use is very long you
start over here student ecstasy
pleasures very high pains very low but
over time you're always chasing those
early highs and in the background pain
is rising and the pleasures going down
but if you're addicted you can't stop
even when the pain is dropped from what
I've seen in my life you've just [__]
nailed it yeah you've absolutely because
those first few times people take hard
drugs they get amazing highs and they're
forever chasing that feeling and that
the use of when they took it and as I
get people get older and they're still
hammer on the drugs it just becomes sad
it's it's quite pathetic that's why I
explained to the school kids because you
can't go into say drugs of fun yeah I
say here's what happened the pleasures
high in the beginning
and you as you go down that road pain
rise in the background and if you get
addicted you can't stop
so I credit the SWAT team with taking me
off that road halfway down it in the
jail
the prisoners ninety percent shooting up
heroin crystal meth two-thirds Hep C
killing them have to say to CC yellow
jaundice skin T Friday L to get
treatment for hepatitis C to save their
own lives they got to stop taking the
drugs they're so addicted they're
choosing to keep taking the drugs and
buy they just can't stop it's really sad
and you know I fought prisoners with
pedophiles murderers robbers did not
it's society's most vulnerable people in
general there's a small minority of
violent prisoners of what the media
keeps everyone frightened with well yeah
because they use them as as we do in all
groups or of any group of people the
media only talk about the extreme
version of that it's a way I'll let you
believe that whatever group they're
talking about this one or two people
represents that whole group yeah you
know D the prosecutor who was trying to
[__] you over constantly yeah
you know how you sort of look at the
SWAT team as the intervention I like her
now as well incorrect read it and how do
you feel even though she try to [__] you
over and keep you in jail for four times
the length but not angry person or a
bitter person I thought harbor ill will
towards anybody and it's just bad waste
of mental energy and I look at the wild
lifestyle I was leading Sammy the boss
son telling me I had been dispatched to
kidnapped me one night basically out to
the desert if I had kept on in that
lifestyle even though I quit the deer
they might have gone back to it might
have ended up dead
so they I'm taking me off that road and
forcing me it was egotistical
narcissistic thought I knew everything
it's a go in prison and get on this
fantastic journey through literature and
realize how much there was to learn how
little I didn't know and send my life in
this new path all those things had to
come together and to make that happen so
how long did you spend in prison in
total and and how did you go about
getting out alright then so as a
first-time nonviolent drug offender I
like to serve just under six years got
out at the end of my sentence got on
Connor before I got out when you get out
people try and trip you up so you get in
trouble and you extend your stay
mmm-hmm so this was the very end of it I
got assigned to kitchen duty
and kitchen is hell nobody wants working
unless you want to steal food and extra
food it's the flat output but at the low
level it's hell in there like there's
this big dishwasher thing it's like a
car wash your size gas is shooting out
of it and it's the explode in fights in
and it's just mental so nice so I'll
take a break my job is to other guys
coming to chow
they've got like 15 minutes to get serve
the trade I get a tray appears in a hole
in the wall and they take it and then
they put the tray back in another hole
in the wall so sooner trays come in and
have to spray all these trays off and
we're washing them and stuff very
quickly before the next batch to come in
so I took a break from this and i sat on
a crate and this guy comes up he goes
that's my chair yeah that's it then it's
as simple as that let's there's an issue
this guy's murdered two people in prison
already if I get off the Craig I'm a
punk and everyone's gonna play on me if
I stay on the crate I've got a beef with
him
well that's only one person so what you
do stay on the crate because you don't
know beef everybody else so I stayed on
the crate and then he said I said that's
they I'm gonna get you it's quite an
immature sort of attitude and I thought
I was told early on prison is high
school mentality with deadly
consequences
it's Lord of the Flies isn't it in many
years
totally I'm not sure they mind they're
not you know they're not going oh we're
mature you know you're I actually I
should stop that yes I work out part of
the time called Iron Man and he was
among other nicknames yeah
who's Marty you still Shawn what's your
name at this English English or no no I
dropped that a shot yeah they named me
England in prison England okay English
Sean's in England nice the only Britain
there um generally they were hardly any
Brits in that was wild man and his ass
calfs woman wild woman okay she was in
prison bleep she was they were the
freemen co-defendants was me wild man a
wild woman okay she was number two
actually she was she almost killed him a
few times sure their relationship is
based on domestic violence and
go over and she did like she like froa
froa
snapped them in the belly or something I
need not of knocked the teeth out sure
I'd have the second ball Hospital didn't
threaten in Ichi on the next day they
were like love you love you the makeup
sex and they would just be back back to
it yeah so so I'm man I am man he says
this dude's been shot already in the
prison system when he was murdering
these guys and now he's got an iron rod
in his leg and I'm gonna teach you some
martial arts move martial arts is banned
in prison so we've got this little room
at the top of a road it's ironic because
they're teaching people how to not be a
tucked and written that I mean jujitsu
be ideal yeah I'll go also you are
teaching prisoners then to defend
themselves when you need to beat them
down well the thing is they rape us they
just put you in a chokehold and put you
to sleep and there's loads of em Seekonk
out of it and you wake up but it's
already happened right yeah yeah so ia
man's like it's teaching me these kicks
to do on this guy's leg completely alone
we're up in this room on the end of a
run and the guards there was one guard
back then called the bloodhound because
he could smell hooch from a hundred
yards away and he was sneaking up on us
one night and we we sent something and
we just bust out some yoga positions as
he jumped in this room we were like BofE
like this they're in like tree pose so
he couldn't write us a disciplinary
ticket for martial arts so this guy's
running his mouth saying he's gonna get
me for a couple of days every night I'm
in my cell got my got my sneakers on
waiting for this to happen didn't want
to go to his cell cuz then I'm the
aggressor I could get my sentence
extended if he comes to my cell it's on
the camera and it would come in one
night and I'm thinking yeah it's gonna
go off I turn around and get ready get
in the position I guess there's a look
in his eyes a friend sleeping Swan yeah
and as I look in his eyes like
something's not gonna go down and I say
what's up and he says Shawn I'm about to
get released I've done 30 plus years
yeah I murdered those guys that was a
long time ago I want my life back
and I said I didn't know that you've
murdered two people that's all I know
how do you think that makes me feel I
think I'm gonna be number three
he says a lot I'm a hardcore heroin
addict I don't know how long I'm gonna
last when I get out he's like can you
help we want to get out can you couldn't
could someone that she know she can
someone show me around could can someone
meet me cuz someone's around me
somewhere I start to get really sad you
having a heart-to-heart with a guy I'm
thinking this guy was gonna kill me and
I've just got all this overwhelming
sadness and it's just that thing where
these people are scurry on the surface
but on inside there her in inside
sometimes being vulnerable makes you
lash out before - it's almost like do
unto others before they do it to you so
like thus the mentality people grow up
with these lot a lot of I mean they're
victims to start off with and then they
become the aggressor to stop themselves
from being a victim anymore exactly they
were right they were molested as kids in
front away his kids raised on the street
seen parents murdered seen I heard a lot
of sad stories and it opened my hearts
what was going on and I just thought
that was really sad and then of the beef
was squashed after that so what did you
do to help did you try a female friend
who was visiting me and and we've talked
about her helping in when he got boy he
had actually arranged some other stuff I
mean the last thing he said to me was if
he could get his passport and come to
England would I show him around but I've
never heard from him since those guys
what happens is they say we're going to
get out and we're going to get off the
drugs and we're gonna get a job and then
six months later you don't hear from
them
they say they're gonna keep in touch you
don't hear from them till they get real
rested for drugs yeah Paul had told us
that story about how he was getting
released and he had it all in his mind
he had a girlfriend having a baby
everything was gonna be great and
literally they released him with another
heroin addict who he knew and he didn't
even make it to the house all such agree
was already going to get more drugs I
was amazed by that story I was listening
to it was great and so when you when you
did gets up on we got out you dodged all
these people's traps to keep you in
prison yeah what happens then on that
day when you know you're getting out
when I got out it was a weird situation
because my sentence Adam come up in the
computer arena we're still showing that
was supposed to serve more far I'm not
gonna get out and it was delayed a few
days and finally the deportation guards
come and they take me to a federal
deportation prison which is nearly all
Mexicans in Arizona so I'm the only
English dude in there and then I'm in
there for a few weeks they can't tell
you release date for security purposes
they flew that have you seen that movie
Connor
oh I've seen it man I was on it Connor
for a few days
[__] me Arizona and California picking
up and dropping off Mexicans and in the
end they put me in in a juice in it yeah
of course I've seen Connor yeah all
right MIT Bob though it's a cool it's a
great man that is though isn't it they
they put me on a flight from LA for
Heathrow what's Mel Gibson like they say
we're gonna take your chains off you
don't try anything stupid
and then Blunden cabin coup our targets
black I'm a human being I can't believe
some sandwich well when we got on the
plane the women come on man I can smell
the woman's sense and the perfumes and
that's just going to my head and I've
not a shower for days I'm thinking I'm
thinking I'm getting all paranoid and
and they're thinking the same thing he's
[__] stink yeah yeah yeah probably
and you I went to the actually one of
the first was this I put my hand up left
permission to use the toilet because I
might have a birdbath to clean myself up
and she the lady like you don't need to
ask it's right there because the staff
no time of course come out of prison I'm
a bit institutionalized and then the
video you saw of me at the airport
getting driven back from the airport I'm
like that and I've got a bit of a beard
and there's a video they just literally
got enough for playing and his family
are recording them on their camera
phones and the car this 2007 wasn't it
yeah well it was uploaded then and it's
funny cuz they're texts then and he's
gone
what you doing I need for everyone or
text anyone what's that this is how
everyone talks now and then he's looking
at the phones and he's looking on the
cars in each one
what's a conch cuz that's a mini goes
minis
yeah and you could just say in a short
space of time a lot had changed cuz I
don't know in that period of time
technology especially had gone through a
[__] huge change yeah definitely so
my mom said it was like a puppy dog
falling around the house waiting for
orders first year I got offered the
opportunity speaking skills but I wasn't
mentally ready for it it's something
about a year and a half I got out before
I did my first talk at schools and I was
Oscar I couldn't even eat my breakfast I
paced like a prisoner miss out the front
of the room and the guy calm a moment
said they musta fall I was completely
crazy but the school invited me back and
I got my confidence up and that's led to
me doing all these talks that's at
school kids how did you find public
speaking in general because I know
you've done a TED Talks and yen and
that's one of the most intimidating
things people can do in terms of
speaking to a people because it's a big
deal isn't it like I said earlier I came
into drugs because I was self medicating
for anxiety and that's always gonna be a
part of me some of that anxiety and
first time I did it so like I said I was
so nervous but the therapist said when
you're afraid of something you gotta hit
hit it head-on
don't hide out from it so I kept the
public speaking in the schools up to the
point where I don't get nervous now
talking for our kids Ted in Switzerland
was such a big deal for me I did get
nervous I'm a mouth went dry right away
I did pick up
I thought you held it together really
well thank us as someone who knows what
take the speak in front of a crowd of
people yeah you can you can pick up on
the little things that that person has
gone through yeah but I thought
[__] hell I would have been like I
need a drink ages ago but you kept going
because there was no water drink would
have solved it so for my second center I
hired a coach and she looked at my first
head sight and she's like you're
hyperventilating
you've got up speak on the end of your
sentences you're laughing and
appropriately
he's taking you spending too long for
when they're applauding and holy seven
eight this ace public species trying to
get you to perfection yeah she's gonna
be overly critical isn't sure so I was
very pleased with my performance at my
second TED talk but the volumes who ever
recorded the volume is a bit screwy
right
but you can't you can't go and see those
online on what your talks called first
one is how facing to what facing
theology has taught me about happiness
yeah I watched that one year and the
second one was overcoming fear and
building resilience in America's
deadliest jails okay yes and also you've
gone on yeah yeah yeah my life stories a
trilogy hard time I think people
watching this are probably most into
hard time the new addition which is
about a hundred pages longer one of the
biggest stories from that which I didn't
tell you is there is the prison riot I
was in well yeah so like I mentioned
earlier we've got the whites the blacks
the Mexicans the mexican-americans for
gangs I'm in a part that's designed for
15 people but it's got 45 in it so
they're all but so many tables in the
day and where they sit at I've seen
those on I don't know if you've watched
them 60 days inside where they put
regular people yeah yes like which I
[__] Louis like that so exactly yeah
what happens is the head of the blacks
is a guy called knockout he's a pro
fighter boxer what a McMahon and he's
never lost a fight knockout Anthony
Joshua's put big brother I'm from
domained he's never lost a fight in the
jail so he starts bullying members of
all the other races for commissary you
spend $20 if your family will put money
on your books get some peanut butter
some peanuts and snacks to supplement
the buy it cause the buy it or we can
get to that if you want sometimes I dead
rats in it so he's sweating people for
extra food and people intimidated by him
so they start complaining to their
respective heads of the races the
respective heads of the races get
together they have a meeting without the
head of the blacks what we're gonna do
about this guy right if one person goes
in he's just gonna knock them out he's
gonna say the issue squash I've earned
my right to stay so what we'll do is
we'll all send the torpedo in what's a
torpedo all right when you first go into
the gang dicks sort of jelly the gang
comes up to explains all the rules
basically a little list of prison
basically you go have showers I will
smash you for bad hygiene right I'll go
make you friends of the guys will smash
engine can't go sitting at the tables to
the races will smash you for that and so
on and so forth now if you what was the
question again what what is a toss-up
you know a torpedo if you violate the
rules they send in what's called a
torpedo a torpedo is someone who's a
junior member looking to earn his
reputation with the gang bunch of young
hot bust and get his tattoos right I
know questions that's a one from each
gang I'll be going in yeah so it's going
to have a right [__] time on his
hands a torpedo from each gang going in
and free torpedoes outside station just
in case oh yeah he's got no chance of
rainbow attack doing away mate get on it
because I watch this [__] 15 quid you
got the white sarpy though the main
white top is cowboy dude soft as hell
the Mexicans are pedo big Mexican dude
called Diablo I can't remember the
Mexican American taught me like mm what
his name was so there you go in a room
it's two storey floors of cells in a
room standard like you saw 60 minutes in
yeah I'm on the phone some a girlfriend
they go in the cell upstairs and the
commotion starts and I don't know what's
going on yet but the blacks are playing
cards at a table and they hear it so
their minds upstairs and they're and
they're not there to defend him they not
know how to defend him well this forty
five man pod there's ten blacks or less
so they were massively out manned they
start to try and get up the stairs and
the torpedos outside the cell the backup
crew start fighting
big blacks trying to get up the stairs
one black guy was like um it was the
wait about three or four hundred pounds
he came down the stairs like a bomb well
not everybody down I'm having visions of
hook where red ball becomes stolen the
plunk yeah yes people start picking up
mops and brooms and doing ninja moves
this would've been [__] below because
these guys are upstairs oh yeah what
happened in that in that cell no it's
igniting it's a full-fledged rate riot
mmm
the guards are supposed to wait for
backup but we've got the two toughest
guards I ever met in that jail on duty
that day one of them puts a spacesuit on
get a fire extinguisher spacesuit you
mean like a spectacle to say yeah it's a
fire extinguisher sized canister of
chemical spray he's coming he's turned
the phone off now so I'm not talking to
my missus anymore I'm trying to get up
the stairs but there's the battle on the
stairs so I'm getting pushed down he's
about to come in the dayroom door right
where I'm at at the bottom stairs I
think I'm gonna get sprayed first we
start spraying the guys doing the ninja
moves first whenever I play games you
always start with a ninja so yeah I like
what he's saying yeah as soon as that
spray hits the of any of you guys been
sprayed no I'm a it look at Lee not you
your eyes yeah the snot drips out your
nose you get this I've seen the program
where the the gods get trained and they
all have to actually be sprayed in order
to pass out yeah and they'll really
don't like when it happens for them it's
[__] awful and my weight well money
he'd like to get sprayed and tasered
we've got off on that Wow so the guards
the girls the girls lie about to come in
and I think you [__] you know he's gonna
spray mix that spray in the ninja guys
and then that hits the atmosphere and
everyone starts to disperse and you know
the backups come in so you don't want to
get grabbed by the backup cuz then
you're gonna get put in lockdown so I go
back to my cell I've got two cell mates
and meme security one of them's an old
timer he says here's what you do in a
riot situation when you've been sprayed
because my eyes are stinging you wrap a
wet towel around your head and you just
blink over and over and over and it
washes to spray out your eyes will
naturally wash the spray out so that's
what I did so did that for a bit but I'm
like getting curious about what's going
on outside so I'm peeping out this towel
looking looking at what's going on and
what happened was the cell that the free
Tapia's had gone in originally the
cowboyed a white dude had grabbed the
black guy in a headlock from behind but
cause he was a feint right cause he was
a trained fighter he knew what to do in
that circumstance he pushed the guy back
against the wall sandwiched him flicked
his head back and instantly broke his
nose now most of the torpedoes had gone
and it was it was just left with the
white and the black dudes fighting and
they wouldn't stop and the guard just
opened up word to spray on the cell just
died and they were fighting blind
basically and then they just waited
until they stopped fighting blind and
the white dude came out first with his
nose pointing in a new angle
and in this polite cowboy twang he says
to the guards before you handcuff me Jim
I never put my nose back into place Wow
oh my god just like yeah shot yeah crack
on crack just crap it back in Wow and
then I got handcuffed and knockout comes
out looks like I'm gonna get all you
guys for this three have enough [__]
pain apart as well you stay yeah at that
point yeah he's [__] at that point his
friends know that he's a target they'll
not be leaving him alone but in that way
then told him that is I mean he must
have been his he's never lost a fight in
arousable I was aware he got moved
around different areas and because he'd
stopped he stood up he actually didn't
become a target you actually people
people just like kind of left him alone
yeah yeah yeah Wow well the bravest
people I ever met was this guy - born
sick almost six and a half four he made
knockout look small right to be born US
Marine yep T bomb he was dispatched to
South America go into some horrific
violence down
and marine as a Marine yeah and when I
first saw t-bone walking across the
prison yard it looked like something out
of a corn and movie and cause of the
rules of racial separation and the
factory we saw bales intimidate I would
have ordered and actually got up and
spoke to him but he knew I was blogging
this was later towards the end of my
stay and he one day I'm just writing at
myself and something appears at my door
completely blocking the sunlight out and
it's him and you should stop down his
pants his entire body is covered in
scars not a little scars like horseshoe
sighs scars and he starts asking your
England and English history and my blog
in and every single fight was just a
different life and death prison fight
story what my only was he standing up
for himself he was stopping the raping
of the young people coming in he's very
religious he said it was his Christian
duty and that God had his back and to
this day still sends me his letters he's
got a Facebook page Tebow and
appreciation sighted it was just
suggested by the students 10,000
followers on it now it's a highlight of
his days reading the questions from him
comments so this they still standing up
for young people he doesn't know
and risk in his life over and over again
this guy's got the biggest heart I've
ever met of anyone's it stupid to be
doing this in a cutthroat environment
for no reward what makes you think how
did someone who's such a good bloke as
you see him marine yeah end up there
drugs
nearly everyone drugs same thing gar the
Marines set himself up as a bodyguard
make ups a thousand a day yeah invested
into cocaine and then always it's done
over 30 years now I'll revolve around
cold in his fifties yeah so what are
your plans for the future me write my
life story is spent me I spend about ten
years writing it like I mentioned to you
earlier I've sweated and to do all these
public all these promotional things you
know I sold half a million pounds of
book to Random House got paid two
thousand every six months so I've just
set up my own publishing not the best
publishing deal you've ever heard that's
just traditional publishers will pay
that much on a 10 pounds book 38 pounds
5% whatever it is that's a [__]
unless your agents fee disgraced or
isn't a true
so excited to be officers I wanted to
and I appreciate them setting me up as
an offer I wouldn't a got into broke
through or if they had to help me do
that
but they're telling themselves a lot law
yeah [__] what time comes when you learn
the ropes I put my Pablo Escobar's book
out it became an instant bestseller you
ever seen that it's gonna have helped
you that there was also narcos on well I
thought I've got to stop writing about
myself something's wrong here let's
start writing about things that are more
important to me Pablo Escobar and it
became an is the best cell numbers on
yeah so it's not be ten years alone it's
not writing about myself so notice of
making money from him and Amazon have
done something to do without ya know
season one and two is about him right
and I've got a book coming out about the
Cali cartel time for narco season three
ok because they think that's season
three is obviously not about him no it's
the aftermath of what his family might
be a little bit all the Cali cartel they
took over the business and part of part
of I guess the the problem with the
Netflix story was that a lot of people
from his family naturally disputed it so
is this a different version of that
story I'm in touch with someone an
intermedia right now to possibly publish
Juan Pablos next book because the
traditional publishers won't publish it
because it goes against that DAA
narrative
yeah and it explains that Pablo in the
very beginning was in bed with the CIA
because the CIA were looking to finance
a war in Nicaragua and they it was
illegal for them to do it so they
allowed the Nicaraguan rebels to dealing
cocaine cocaine to finance this war and
Pablo was well there so many people have
reportedly been in bed with the CIA who
they use them as tools until they're no
longer abuse and then they turn on them
exactly they say somehow bin Laden was
also one of those people it's a standard
thing yeah I don't think that happens in
general Noriega well it doesn't happen
anymore
Donald Trump Donald with none of those
guys alright and he said he was gonna
splinter the CIA in two thousand pieces
and then BOOM goodnight yeah so if your
laws enable you guys are gonna die no my
Pablo sales has enabled me to set up my
own publishing company which have just
registered through cooperation
corporations house armless mom
okay great I'm gonna that's got beyond
narcos for those guys who are wondering
about that one because that's probably
gonna be ready for I'm now I'm gonna
read this Thanks I mean you'll have to
buy your own letter my copy you can get
Amazon yeah I was on world wise I mean a
little borrowing on everyone but yeah
sure the public speaking is my own thing
the over 100 talk to year presently at
schools in the beginning you know how to
market it and try and get in but now
other schools they tell other schools in
fact me back every year and it's just
going on its own and I love is all the
feedback from the kids and sometimes the
parents parents have a sumeet neither
say stuff like we're lucky if we can get
a grunt out of our kid when he gets home
from school after watching your tour it
was the first time we could sit down and
talk about drugs of our child now he
wants to be a criminal with the dead
rats in the food the cockroaches all
over it nice the gang stuff and the
Prison Rape and you know did the things
that can happen if you get go down that
road and so are you also working things
about that because you seem very
passionate about the problems in the
American yeah it's something that's very
difficult to kind of activists against
activist I activist against because it's
so embedded your voice is gonna be one
of many but there's an inflection point
because people are sick of the war on
drugs the sick of the racism all these
black guys being in prison America
because there's this this racist drug
czar if they thought you know they rate
white women on drugs and the backlash
has been this decriminalization we
because the war on drugs is a war on
people possessing weed it's not a war on
heroin addicts and all this office of
crystal meth it's millions on one
hundreds of thousands a year as for weed
and it's all keeping this prison
industrial complex in business the
politicians Democrats Republicans they
take millions from the private prisons
to keep this in place what the people at
the state level of voting
we're sick of it we're not we're not
sending our kids to prisons for food
anymore in America under civil avisek
confiscate your laws
if teenagers are driving around
apperance car with weird please can take
the car sees that keep it so it's
systemic sort of taking away people's
finances and obviously it makes a lot of
people get more desperate for money
what's the natural way of getting more
money dealing in drugs it's gone it's
gone to such an extreme over there that
there's a backlash against it should
there be a half a million women in
prison in America nearly the majority
nonviolent drug offenders prisons were
designed for pedophiles murderers
rapists women are now most women out
doing these things
yeah and so that I mean but it's very
difficult can you go back to the states
banned for life right yeah I mean you
probably pick the best time to be bad
listening but you you know you mate you
made the most of it while you were there
let's play that America was good to me I
maxed it out and it was a full
responsibility for [__] up and put
myself in the jail you're also there a
great time in America weren't you did
you travel around a lot or were you
predominant eat well that was the time
when the stock market was really
bubbling and I found it good to make
that money did you go to New York LA you
traveled around a bit went to Las Vegas
got married on the Las Vegas Strip to
which one is good
so I mentioned al she's bisexual and one
of the things that really got Iraq if
mentioned was having a woman come in and
give us both oral sex and then me and
her
shagging right so it was like the
foreplay thing yeah so Las Vegas Strip
we get married in one these little Elvis
places and then we're walking back and
she's like to celebrate why don't we
have a threesome let's go on into
brothels
so start calling all the brothels and
then they say are we were gentlemen's
clubs you can't allow women in like what
is this [__] so there's people on the
strip handing out these little sleazy
magazines and we get back to the room
where she's gone for this magazine she's
excited
married at this point as well I mean so
we call this one I'm like yeah here's
the deal we can't get in the gentlemen's
clubs my wife is bisexual can you send
the lady out that would you know perform
services for both of us
no problem hundred fifty dollars two
hundred dollars an hour whatever it was
so I said yeah cool we're at this hotel
so she comes this gorgeous brunette
comes out always blonde and she sees my
wife doing a cult she's like gonna do a
bit the coke and all right yes she does
some coke so the first thing is my
wife's gonna go and and just receive
oral sex on this one we explained we're
not gonna have sex with the prostitute
right we're just both gonna get oral sex
me and wife's gonna go first so I'm just
watching this on the bed I'm getting so
turned on it's my turn right
so she says can I have more coke I'm a
figure she's high enough and we look at
each other because we're living in
Mexico my [__] it's not like it is in
this country it's not got all this baby
laxative and a baby powder and black
butt stuff and laxatives in it
so we're looking at will let you show
you what more your sins you've you've
got the real [__] yeah so she's fiend in
we think she might be fiend in so we say
yeah I spoil the party and she gets on
me and it's like almost nice white slow
like variously furiously cuz the cocaine
is taking at maximum effect sure higher
so I'm barely holding on to my not at
this point cuz she's going so hard and
fast right I wanna have sex with my wife
so I'm trying to save it
right so in the end we like we call
timeout give it a call timeout I know
and then we say you got a go now
basically
she's our resident evils as found in it
the doesn't want to go
not with a call I bet you she was on the
stations point you're in a Las Vegas
hotel room with your newly married
lesbian wife married by Elvis yeah okay
[Laughter]
make sure you watch the lot you [__]
it's hard to come on gamma hydroxide
boots may as well which is what I'm on
yeah but she's going so friends I'm on
the edge I'm on the edge I want to do
the kids a life story she's slightly
offered to come we move to Tucson with
us in the house at losing it got rid of
air we gave a number we promised we
would go out on the town of a club in in
Vegas and blah blah blah and you told
[__] she went yeah and were you in a
fancy hotel Vegas or is this like one of
those look because when I stand in Vegas
I was on those shitty motels you know
you won't initiate a peak of my money
right see you were in a ball in yeah MGM
grand style Caesars Palace okay yeah
water situations Ben yeah unlucky me I
really hope one day I'm gonna live that
sentence where it is just okay
I'm just hoping some one day someone
makes that into a short there's definite
short film in there isn't there sort of
they could do a call too and also lets
the glamorize over the oxide down so she
got so deeply into drugs my wife after
we after us at split she wants to kill
herself and she had this romantic idea
of buying like Cleopatra in Egypt right
it's got a one-way tickets Egypt yeah
getting bit by snake yeah no snakes
available us Just My Luck
so she gets a pill cocktail slams the
pill cocktail and then just slashed her
wrist [__] but she did get found by the
staff might have been a cry for help I
don't know and she got rescued and she
survived and went on all over the world
teaching in China teaching in Africa and
doing good things and you still know now
still no no everyone in my books cuz
that's a sign legal papers saying this
is accurate otherwise so they could sue
me they could sue the publisher so yeah
you know you're saying you're not
glamourizing and we're certainly not
right we're laughing at the how crazy
your life was definitely not laughing at
the drugs and that but cuz you know a
few people have had a little dick at
work a few people have been very worried
about about telling stories like this
and it's sort of being like well well
yes I'm very glamorous yeah but one
thing you did mention was at one point
during the first few years of your stay
in prison you've yourself felt like
suicidal and oh god yeah oh how bad did
it go for you right for first year I'm
pining for my old life start back what
my house what my swimming pool all that
stuff missing my bird she's my lifeline
she's visiting me three times a week
prosecutor to increase pressure because
I'm not breaking down sign the plea
bargain gets my bail doubled get moved
over to maximum security don't know
anyone murderers cockroaches cockroaches
are all over me at nights four or five
days you can't sleep hearing voices
seeing imaginary things I've got all
these bleeding and itching skin
infections and bed sores I've got a pink
eye infection eyelids drooping down here
yellow pus coming up my eyeball they
stopped my girlfriend for visiting me by
indicted her for one prescription pill
found in our medicine or our bathroom on
in the cabinet on the day of the raid
without a written prescription right
next to it which is a class 6 felony
yeah co-defendants can't visit
co-defendants issues you just
criminalized her so far to stop her from
visiting me there really turn on its
grow onion and only say 200 years every
time you spoke about drugs on the phone
he's 5 to 10 you go to trial and lose
we're gonna stack it up to 200 year
sentence so I'm like do I want to spend
the rest of my life in an environment
like this I can't take it anymore so a
plan to slash my wrists after regard to
the security walk but before I was gonna
do it I want to say goodbye to my mom
and dad and my sister my girlfriend I
mean but that was I had seven photos so
get the fault was out I'm looking at my
mom and dad and my sister and my
girlfriend I'm thinking you know mom's
gonna get a call saying is sliced his
wrists in an Arizona jail cell I just
got I just got really sad I started
crying and I thought I just can't put my
mom through that mmm that's that's what
stopped me from doing it and I felt
selfish the next day I want to kill
myself because a prisoner came in and
told me his sad story had stomach cancer
he's gonna die now you had a metal rod
in his leg he was in agony he had
syphilis
Hep C and cancer and he was in agony
when he pissed and went on the toilet
and I'm thinking this guy's gonna die
now felt sorry for myself last night
and that was the turning point when you
are thinking about 200 years and then
you get sentenced to nine and a half
yeah I'm gonna get my life back crazy
yeah who gives a [__] pop the house on
the mountain who gives a [__] about the
date triangle [__] about you plasma
screen TV I just like back and the start
think about the needs of the prisoners I
started to help them read their legal
paperwork further and couldn't read or
write it's hard enough for me to
understand the legal terminology I
started a class for the Mexicans well I
haven't worked out in the country
couldn't write home in Spanish I did
some basic and it was basic Spanish
Aryan Brotherhood prison gang had a
problem because I helped another race
well I psalm it was an independent tough
guy Annie intervene with the gang and
they allowed me to continue and if
I'll thing it is it to try help people
was a guard said to me the world has got
no idea what's going on in here
but all the human rights violations yeah
and that's what motivated me to start
writing it down
my aunt smuggled it out of maximum
security risk in herself got put on the
Internet as John's jail jail so they
wouldn't know my real name the guards
and that went on to attract
international media attention and that's
what's led to everything
that came from helping other people I
never set out to benefit myself what
helping off people put some it was a
break on your ego and it's good for your
soul that leads to good things like like
I became an offer because of it gave me
the credibility to do talks in the
schools and sent me on this whole new
positive path and it's amazing really
how quickly things can turn for someone
then you know you've gone down a very
negative route for a very long time
maybe don't realize it cuz you're
enjoying it and suddenly I think the
average person watching this short and
especially when I was younger we all
feel like the decisions you make don't
really have that much of an impact of
where your life's gonna go yeah that's
[__] like the decisions you make
will define your exact like it's gonna
make a huge difference to your life and
that long road you're going further down
the road and you've proven how on a good
decision it can go like that and on a
bad decision it can go [__] like that
you know I'm saying but we most people
feel like helpless like when they make
and how if what is difference doesn't it
make if I take this subject in college
or that so I get this job or that job
but it does make a [__] huge
difference and you've paid the price of
it but you've also redeemed your
Sullivan you paid the price and now
trying to help young people not make my
mistakes
well done it I'm probably honestly I
think it's good that what you're doing
and I don't got any other questions
because I'm I mean no I think I think
we've covered a lot there I think we
will be worth you know go over and watch
some of your videos I'll put all the
links below so you've got you've got
lots of content out there yeah things
you do yeah I don't think he's your
typical youtuber yet he's not one of
those sort of morning guys just going in
through my old prison flawless
you know it is in YouTube I just have
social media every channel yeah
obviously yeah I think a lot of people
could be quite cynical about you know
people who want to tell their own story
but I think it is quite a genuine story
and this there's a lot of lessons in
there for people's yeah yeah thanks a
lot for putting those things out those
before you [__] you guys having me on
it's been really great and you know
looking at your own videos as well spend
my breakfast now and stuff later
Wow you surprised you can eat your
breakfast listen to some of the stuff
that comes out is another story like
yours that's for [__] sure how do you
survive I mean you said obviously
there's peanut butter and stuff in
prison that you can buy right dead rats
and right in in the room and jail when
you first go in this was the hardest
crawl part was the remand jail mm-hmm
breakfast comes in a plastic bag yeah
moldy bread and green Bologna green
Bologna is the raw sausage meat gone
past this salt by day it's got green
shine to it so a lot of the food was in
boxes that businesses were throwing away
because it had expired mold on the bread
blue green sometimes our mold came in
these fantastic psychedelic colors look
actually look like works of ours and
we're so hungry we're just scraping the
mold off because we've got to get some
calories in us just trying to sustain
ourselves even a meal that was the
mystery meat slop called red death look
like carrot a vomit blended with blood
all kinds of random meat in it and it
stung occasionally there was a dead rat
in it because their mass bringing these
ingredients to the kitchen with back to
Somalia right we actually we actually
complained to a Garth we said there's a
rat and they said well they took it and
said they'll investigate it I saw the
jail won't get any trouble they came
back later in the day saying it was just
a potato
well I'm thinking how can i outsmart
Taylor's legs yeah don't forget alkali
outsmart the system just started
noticing the Jewish diet was the best
you have a right of freedom of religious
expression which included food yeah so
you got all these guys lining up for the
Jewish diet in kind of Haman you've got
Nazis
dude I saw Nazi guy in there
Hitler Zeke hailing on his chest over
Jews dying in the gas chamber fortune oh
yeah so you got all these nuts he's
lying enough for the Jewish diet got
Mexican Mafia juice Italian mafia Jews I
figured I got I got a plus that play in
this system so what I did was I I
converted to the Hindu religion to get a
vegetarian religious layup yeah and
because the people who come and
interview you about your religion are
Christians there's a book called the
backup at Gita yeah by Gita and they
couldn't they didn't know about it so
they didn't really question because it
just gave me anyway so so much for a
smite in the system anyway in the room
and really didn't work it were later on
in into prison so instead of the green
baloney for breakfast I did get a little
thing of peanut butter but it was rank
it was like burns it tasted foul and in
the evening I saw Emil and it was like a
veggie burger but it was as hard as a
discus got to put it in water to get it
down I don't know what was in it but my
breath was filed for like three days
afterwards if my girlfriend visited you
were even brushing my teeth and bitten
stop it and then I saw that it came with
sports an English man in eSports yeah
got all excited I get my spark in there
and I notice all the lesions and for
some reason nearly every night it was
long strands of human right yeah you
must also seen some pretty horrific
tattoos so all kind of tattoo yeah I
mean that one's definitely a prison
tattoo is not the kind of thing that you
so go from yes you're not going to a
normal tattoo artist and going hitler's
'highly above the yeah that's not if
you're clicking up with the Aryan
Brotherhood let's say you collect the
debt might get a swastika or SS
lightning bolts right murder someone but
you got most on to be a full member
get a warbird a Aryan Brotherhood patch
and then you see the gang members I
South American gangs Mexican gangs
lot of them are into the teardrop yeah
so solid the teardrop is one person you
murdered for you gang what if he's an
empty one that's always gonna ask any
guys no one empty one is attempted
murder its sorrow the present one of the
present definitions biggest one is its
sorrow for the loss of a fellow gang
member right and then when you murdered
a rival who's murdered your fellow gang
member you fill it in so that it's
fascism an earlier definition
from the teardrop was that after they
raped you they put a teardrop on you as
well well that's changed from that now
so hard to tell it's more what no now
the president is there weren't it
proudly enough for murdering people or
lost lots of a gang member because if
you've been raped you're pumped out and
that's the other Louis little low in the
spectrum yeah yeah so some pretty
tattoos yeah change meaning when you
come you got guys who flames on the
heads and all the faces tatted and it's
just I was the odd man out they call me
a blanky
yeah no tattoos everyone in there is is
tatted almost the guide the serial home
invader torture he turned our cell into
a legal tattoo shop and he had hepatitis
C and I was on the top bunk and he was
his leavin he was leaving his needles
out so they were sticking me and one day
I did I started on one of his needles
and he went right into my foot I'm
thinking I'm gonna get hepatitis C now
cuz it because of this guy well I didn't
know I got tested for it it's so lucky
yeah you're really lucky to be here at
this point I don't think I've used up my
nine lives yeah yeah how many books you
have now almost then I've got a war on
drugs series so Pablo Escobar and Cali
cartel and yeah how would you want to be
remembered me know been asked that
before
I like ask that one in the end yes I
just want to be remembered as a guy it
meant well but [__] up did some harm
to society sword out of his ways and
then tried to balance the books trying
to restore his karma well it's been a
[Music]
prison handshake yeah is that one it's
been a fascinating shot lads I've
enjoyed it as always but really I was
being a good one I like this hopefully
you lot enjoyed it as well if you have
like we know in the comments below I'll
leave the links to this month
books all of his social media there in
the description thanks for watching like
the video and we'll say as layer
you